Hello, everyone. Happy New Year's Eve. Yeah, last day of 2025. We hope you have a safe and happy one, but we're here to keep your company. So we have announced that in the new year, we are going to be rewatching the paper. The whole thing, because it is now on NBC, on Monday nights. And to kick things off, we thought we'd rerun our breakdown of the pilot. Yeah, that way you're all ready to go in the new year. with episode two of the paper, which will be coming out next Wednesday. Next Wednesday, 2026, y'all. All right, everybody, have a very happy new year. Here is the Paper Pilot Breakdown. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey.
大家好。祝大家除夕快乐。对，2025年的最后一天。我们希望大家过一个安全快乐的日子，不过我们在这里陪着大家。所以我们宣布，在新的一年里，我们将重温《办公室》（The Paper）。整部剧都会重温，因为它现在每周一晚上在NBC播出。为了开个好头，我们觉得重播一下我们对试播集的剖析是个不错的主意。对，这样大家就都能准备好迎接新的一年了，还有《办公室》第二集，将于下周三播出。下周三，2026年，各位。好了，祝大家新年快乐。以下是《办公室》试播集剖析。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。
We were on The Office together, and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello there, everyone. Holy moly, do we have a big episode today? We are going back to the Office Universe.
我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为您制作终极《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妹6.0版。大家好。天哪，我们今天有一集内容丰富的大节目吗？我们要回到《办公室》宇宙了。
We sure are. With the paper. The paper. You guys, the first four episodes are out now on Peacock. Check them out. Today we're going to talk about the pilot. And we got some behind-the-scenes scooped. for you. Behind the scenes, lady, we had exclusive access to the set. We got to talk to the
我们当然要回去。和《办公室》一起。各位，前四集现在已经可以在Peacock上收看了。去看看吧。今天我们要谈谈试播集。我们为你收集了一些幕后爆料。幕后女神们，我们获得了片场的独家访问权。我们采访了
actors. We got to talk to the crew, the writers, the producers. And for those of you have been following along with us, these past four Fridays, we have been releasing some of those interviews with the cast members, some of the people we were able to talk to during our visit. So definitely check those out if you missed them. Well, we've got a lot to discuss. I think we just got to get into it. Let's get into it. Today, we are talking about the paper. This episode is titled Pilot. It was written by Greg Daniels and Michael Komen, Michael Komen, Ellie Kemper's husband. This was directed by Greg Daniels, and this episode is 33 minutes and 18 seconds. Well, here's the thing. Right away something new from the offices, they get to have more time.
演员们。我们采访了剧组工作人员、编剧、制片人。对于那些一直关注我们的朋友，在过去的四周五月份里，我们一直在发布其中一些与演员阵容的采访，也就是我们在访问期间能够交流的一些人。所以如果你错过了，一定要去看看。好了，我们有很多要讨论的。我想我们得直接切入正题了。让我们开始吧。今天，我们要聊聊《办公室》。这一集的标题是试播集。它由格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）和迈克尔·科门（Michael Komen）共同编剧，迈克尔·科门是埃莉·坎珀（Ellie Kemper）的丈夫。本片由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导，这一集时长33分18秒。好了，情况是这样的。办公室的新作品马上带来了一些新变化，他们有更多的时间了。
I know. And how much fun is that? I mean, as I was watching the episode, I was so wishing we could have had this extra 10 minutes per episode because, oh, my gosh, you see what that gives you. Mm-hmm. And I guess thankfully now, Dave Rogers is giving us all of that in the superfan episodes. True. Well, here is your summary, folks. The documentary crew that filmed the office is now looking for a new subject, and they find it in a historic, struggling Midwestern newspaper called the Truth Teller in Toledo, Ohio. The show focuses on the paper's newly hired publisher, Ned, whose goal is to revive the paper using volunteer reporters.
我知道。那有多有趣？我的意思是，当我观看这一集时，我是多么希望每集能多出这10分钟啊，因为哦，天哪，你看到了那会带给你什么。嗯嗯。我想谢天谢地，现在戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）在超级粉丝剪辑版中把所有这些都呈现给我们了。确实。好吧，各位，这是你们的总结。曾经拍摄《办公室》的纪录片摄制组现在正在寻找一个新的拍摄对象，他们在俄亥俄州托莱多市找到了一家历史悠久、苦苦挣扎的中西部报纸，名为《真理报》（Truth Teller）。该剧聚焦于该报新聘用的出版商内德（Ned），他的目标是通过志愿记者复兴这家报纸。
All right, we're going to do fast facts, and Angela, you're going to kick us off. Yeah. All right, fast fact number one. So like we said, we got to interview some of the cast, and we also got to talk to Greg Daniels and Michael Coleman. We asked them if they could share with us about the premise of the paper. Here's what Greg had to say. I do want to preface this with, if you guys have to talk to. haven't listened to the interviews, Jenna and I showed up with only one microphone.
好了，我们要进行快速问答，安吉拉，你来带个头。好的。好的，快速问答第一条。正如我们所说，我们采访了一些演员，我们还采访了格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克尔·科门。我们问他们是否能跟我们分享一下《办公室》的创作前提。格雷格是这么说的。我想在此之前先说明一下，如果你还没有听过这些采访的话，我和珍娜出现时只带了一个麦克风。
And our batteries died on the microphone when it was finally time to talk to Greg and Michael. So we had to plug it in. And then the only way to be close to them is if you and I sat on a conference room table. We have a picture of this, of you and I sitting on a conference room table. Leaning towards them with this one microphone. So if you hear a little clunkiness, it's because we're on a table. Well, the premise of the show is that there is a company that bought Dunder Mifflin. They basically own anything that produces or uses paper. So they have Dunder Mifflin, which is office supplies.
而当我们终于轮到和格雷格以及迈克尔交谈时，麦克风没电了。所以我们不得不把它插上电源。然后，唯一能靠近他们的方法就是你和我坐在会议室的桌子上。我们有一张照片，记录了你和我坐在会议室桌子上的情景。手里拿着这唯一的麦克风向他们倾斜。所以如果你听到一点杂音，那是因为我们坐在桌子上。好吧，这部剧的前提是一家公司收购了邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）。他们基本上拥有任何生产或使用纸张的东西。所以他们拥有邓德·米夫林，也就是办公用品公司。
But their biggest product is toilet tissues and toilet seat protectors. And then they also have a few newspapers because they also use paper. but the newspapers are the least money makers and they're low man on the totem pole. And so the documentary crew is just trying to follow up what happened to Dunder Mifflin and finds that it's part of this conglomerate. And they sort of stumble on an interesting story in the fact that this old newspaper is trying to be revived by an idealistic young publisher. And they think, oh, that'd be a good documentary.
但他们最大的产品是卫生纸和马桶座垫保护套。然后他们还拥有几家报纸，因为他们也用纸。但报纸是最不赚钱的，而且在权力阶层中处于底层。因此，纪录片摄制组只是想追踪邓德·米夫林后来怎么样了，结果发现它是这个大型企业集团的一部分。他们偶然发现了一个有趣的故事，那就是这家老报纸正试图被一位有理想的年轻出版商复兴。他们想，哦，这会是一部很好的纪录片。
and they start following that. Well, I actually think that sounded pretty good for two ladies on a table with one microphone. I know. And Greg, of course, always speaks so well. Yes. Okay. Well, Michael also shared with us, and the sound quality wasn't great on this. So, Michael, I'm just going to read it.
然后他们开始跟踪报道。好吧，我其实觉得对于两个坐在桌子旁、只有一个麦克风的女士来说，这听起来相当不错。我知道。而且格雷格当然总是说得那么好。是的。好吧，迈克尔也跟我们分享了，而且这里的音质不是很好。所以，迈克尔，我来读一下。
I'm sorry. The table microphone set up slowly fell apart on us. Anyway, so Michael shared with us why they thought this story is timely to what is happening right now in a lot of industries. He said that larger companies are acquiring newspapers, and often the newspapers will just function as a ghost paper. They're just sort of used for their name, and people recognize them as a source of news, but they mostly carry stories from the wire that you get on the Associated Press or any other big site, and they just milk them for ads until they disappear.
我很抱歉。桌上麦克风的设置慢慢地散架了。无论如何，迈克尔跟我们分享了为什么他们认为这个故事与当前许多行业正在发生的事情息息相关。他说，大公司正在收购报纸，通常报纸只会作为幽灵报纸运作。它们只是因其名称而被使用，人们将其视为新闻来源，但它们大多刊登来自美联社（Associated Press）或任何其他大型网站的电讯稿件，他们只是榨取它们的广告价值，直到它们消失。
And basically, they keep the newspapers around because they think it's good for the community, but they're not really servicing any news stories. And that just fit in perfectly with the premise of the paper. Well, Greg also shared about the comedy hook of this premise, which is that this dying newspaper only has one reporter. But the new publisher that we're going to meet in this first episode has a lot of ideas about wanting to do original local coverage, but he doesn't have the money to hire reporters. Yeah, so we find out he gets volunteers from the people who already work there. truck drivers, salesmen, accountants, those are the people that become his news team. And, of course, they're total amateurs and, you know, hilarity ensues.
基本上，他们保留报纸是因为他们认为这对社区有好处，但他们并没有真正提供任何新闻报道。这与《办公室》的前提完美契合。好吧，格雷格还分享了这一前提的喜剧笑点，那就是这家垂死的报纸只有一个记者。但在我们在这第一集里将要见到的新出版商，有很多关于想要进行原创本地报道的想法，但他没有钱雇佣记者。是的，所以我们发现他从已经在那里工作的人中招募志愿者。卡车司机、推销员、会计，这些就是成为他的新闻团队的人。当然，他们完全是业余爱好者，你知道的，滑稽的事情接踵而至。
Yes. Spoiler alert, there's a later episode where they invite a bunch of kids in the journalism department of the local college to, like, shadow the newspaper. And you realize that these journalism students know way more. Way more than this rag-tag group of local reporters. Morgan said this. And I really, that was really funny. I know. I love that whatever. When you see it, one character says, can we come and shadow you guys at school? Yeah. Like in your class? Because I'm learning a lot. Amazing. Well, fast fact number two, Greg shared with us that he really did try to recreate the magic that we had on the office. And some of that was in hiring a lot of the same
是的，剧透预警，后面有一集他们邀请了当地大学新闻系的许多孩子来，比如暗中观察这家报纸。你会意识到这些新闻系学生懂得更多。比这群杂牌军般的当地记者懂得多得多。摩根（Morgan）是这么说的。我真的，那真的很有趣。我知道。我喜欢无论如何。当你看到它时，一个角色说，我们能来学校暗中观察你们吗？对。就像在你们班上一样？因为我在学很多东西。太棒了。好吧，快速问答第二条，格雷格跟我们在《办公室》中创造的魔力一样，他确实努力去重现它。其中一部分就是雇用了许多相同的
crew members. So when we visited, we saw a lot of familiar faces. We sure did. And another thing that the office was famous for was having writers who also appeared in recurring roles on the show. And we asked Greg if that was the same thing for the paper. And he said, yeah, pretty much everything that seemed like good luck from back then we tried to recreate. So we have four writer performers. And when we get into the show and we're doing our breakdown, I'll tell you who they are as we meet their characters. I love that Greg brought back so. much of the philosophy of the office. And I think you see it on screen. We'll get to it. We're going to talk about it. But the paper, it feels like the office. Yeah. It's in the universe. It's in the world. Absolutely. Yeah. You feel it on screen. Yeah. Well, Jenna, you've got FastFact three and two words. Oscar Nunez. Yes, Oscar's character is the head accountant for Enervate. Head accountant. Excuse me. Yeah. Uh-huh.
剧组人员。所以当我们访问时，我们看到了很多熟悉的面孔。我们确实看到了。而《办公室》出名的另一件事是拥有也在剧中扮演常驻角色的编剧。我们问格雷格《办公室》是否也是如此。他说，是的，基本上当年所有看起来像是好运的东西，我们都试图重现。所以我们有四个编剧兼演员。当我们进入正剧并进行剖析时，当他们的角色出现时，我会告诉你他们是谁。我喜欢格雷格带回了这么多《办公室》的哲学。我想你在银幕上看到了。我们会讲到的。我们要讨论它。但是《办公室》感觉就像《办公室》。是的。它在这个宇宙中。它在这个世界里。绝对的。是的。你在银幕上能感受到它。是的。好吧，珍娜，你有快速问答第三条，用两个词概括。奥斯卡·努涅斯（Oscar Nunez）。是的，奥斯卡的角色是恩维特公司（Enervate）的首席会计师。首席会计师。不好意思。对。嗯哼。
Yeah, there's three accountants again, but this time, Oscar is the head accountant. Looky, looky at Oscar. Yeah. The accountants cover all of the accounting for Enervate, which is the company that owns both the toilet paper side and the newspaper side. Mm-hmm. And, you know, last time we saw Oscar, he was running for state senator. And Greg said that didn't pan out. So now the fact that Oscar is working at this newspaper is sort of his way of serving the community.
对，这次又是三个会计，但这次，奥斯卡是首席会计师。瞧瞧奥斯卡。是的，会计们负责恩维特公司的所有会计工作，恩维特公司既拥有卫生纸业务，也拥有报纸业务。嗯哼，你知道，我们上次见到奥斯卡时，他正在竞选州参议员。格雷格说那没有成功。所以现在奥斯卡在这家报纸工作，这可以说是他服务社区的一种方式。
And you're going to see that in his character. Again, I don't want to give too many spoilers. You don't want to give too much away, but I would say Oscar's new journey has a little bit of Finer Things Club and a little bit of his heart for service. Yes. Well, we saw Oscar that day on the set. Yeah. And it was so fun to see him in character again. Yeah, we should say we were there for the taping of episode eight. But we were there on set while Oscar was doing. a scene. And we got to sit back in Video Village with Greg and watch Oscar in a scene. Yeah. And Dave Rogers was directing. It was so magical. It felt like a little travel back in time. But we reached out to Oscar for this episode and we asked him a few questions. First one was, how did you get your job on the paper? Ooh, yes. So I have lunch once in a while with Greg
你会在他的角色中看到这一点。再说一次，我不想剧透太多。你不想透露太多，但我会说奥斯卡的全新旅程有一点点“精致生活俱乐部”（Finer Things Club）的影子，也有一点点他为社区服务的心意。是的。好吧，那天我们在片场看到了奥斯卡。是的，再次看到他扮演角色真是太有趣了。是的，我们应该说我们当时在那儿是为了拍摄第八集。但当奥斯卡在拍戏时，我们在片场。我们得以和格雷格一起坐在视频村（Video Village）里看奥斯卡演戏。是的。而且戴夫·罗杰斯在执导。那太神奇了。感觉就像是一次有时光倒流的感觉。但我们为这一集联系了奥斯卡，并问了他几个问题。第一个问题是，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？哦，是的。所以我和格雷格
Daniels, our showrunner from the office. And month. ago, we went out and he said something like, Oscar, I'm thinking of an idea of something, I don't know, a startup with a newspaper or something like that, a paper in the world of journalism, like an old newspaper or something. And how would you feel if your character somehow bled over into that world or was part of that? And I said, yeah, that's fine. It was very, just very shallow, you know, an idea that he had. And then, uh, Time went by weeks and maybe we had another lunch and it was a little bit more fleshed out and this happened a couple times until finally he's like, when did you come by? And they had an office
丹尼尔斯偶尔吃午饭，他是我们在《办公室》的剧集统筹。几个月前，我们出去吃午饭，他说了一些类似于这样的话，奥斯卡，我在想一个关于某事的想法，我不知道，一个关于报纸或类似东西的创业公司，新闻界的世界里的一张旧报纸或类似的东西。如果你的角色不知怎么地融入到那个世界中，或者成为其中的一部分，你会有什么感觉？我说，好吧，这挺好的。当时非常，非常肤浅，你知道的，只是他的一个想法。然后，时间过去了几个星期，也许我们又吃了一次午饭，这个想法更加丰满了一些，这种情况发生了好几次，直到最后他说，你什么时候顺便过来看看？他们在罗伯逊（Robertson）有一个办公室
down on Robertson and I went by and there was the writing team. And that's when I knew, oh, this thing is kind of happening. And so it was a writing team. And then he started to talk, Greg Daniels started to talk about possible people that he had in mind and fleshing out the idea more. And that's how I found out about it in increments. And I was sworn to secrecy from the beginning, of course. So then, of course, we had to ask him about keeping that secret. Yeah. That's a big secret.
我顺便去了那里，编剧团队就在那里。就在那时我知道，哦，这事有点眉目了。所以那是一个编剧团队。然后他开始谈论，格雷格·丹尼尔斯开始谈论他心中的可能人选，并把这个想法充实得更多。这就是我一点一点了解到的。当然，我从一开始就被发誓要绝对保密。所以，当然，我们不得不问他关于保守这个秘密的事情。是的。这是一个巨大的秘密。
Here's what he said. Angela, as you know, Jenna might know, but Angela, definitely, I'm not good at keeping secrets. And it was very difficult. When we shot the pilot, Chris Hasten was there, which is Kate Flannery's boyfriend and photographer. He's a professional photographer. and he was there and he's like Oscar oh my god and uh you know Greg danos told him you have to keep it a secret and he's like oh I've been doing this for a long time and he he found it very easy
他是这么说的。安吉拉，如你所知，珍娜可能知道，但安吉拉，绝对地，我不擅长保守秘密。这非常困难。当我们拍摄试播集时，克里斯·哈斯滕（Chris Hasten）也在那里，他是凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）的男朋友兼摄影师。他是一名专业摄影师。他在那里，他说奥斯卡哦天哪，然后，你知道格雷格·丹尼尔斯告诉他你必须保密，他说哦我已经做这个很久了，他发现这非常容易
to keep the secret from Kate because uh he's been doing this photography for 40 years with all kinds of celebrities and whatnot but it was fun to see him there and uh and we had that secret together and um but I did it I think I did it and then you know the cat got let out of the bag before we they were ready to announce it some reporter got wind of it and and so here we are Well, I remember when we saw that article, Angela, but that was not news to us because, you know, a while back, we ran into someone who we won't say. We can't say. We'll never say. Accidentally let it slip about Oscar to us. I know.
对凯特保密，因为他从事摄影已经40年了，接触过各种名人和形形色色的人，但很高兴能看到他在那里，而且我们一起保守了这个秘密，但是，我做到了，我想我做到了，然后你知道在他们准备宣布之前消息就走漏了，某个记者风闻此事，所以我们就这样了。好吧，我记得当我们看到那篇文章时，安吉拉，但这对我来说不是什么新闻，因为，你知道，不久前，我们遇到了一个人，我们不会说。我们不能说。我们永远不会说。不小心对我们说漏嘴了关于奥斯卡的事。我知道。
And we said we won't. We promise. We promise. And we locked it down. We did. No one knows until right now that we knew. That's right. Like, no one.
我们说我们不会。我们保证。我们保证。我们把它封锁了。我们确实做到了。直到现在才知道我们当时就知道。没错。就像，没有人知道。
Yeah, lady. and I would see Oscar at all of these, like, things that our daughters were doing together, and I pretended like I didn't know he was on the paper. He had no idea you knew. Me and Brian and him talked about doing a fan convention together. He had no idea. No. Brian didn't know.
是的，女神。我会所有这些女儿们一起参加的活动上见到奥斯卡，而我假装我不知道他在演《办公室》。他根本不知道你知道。我和布莱恩（Brian）以及他谈论过一起办一个粉丝见面会。他完全不知道。不。布莱恩不知道。
Nobody knew. Yep. You know why? Because we'd log it down. We locked it down. We locked it down. And I'm, like, so curious to ask Kate. Like, Kate, your longtime partner knew.
没有人知道。是的。你知道为什么吗？因为我们把它封锁了。我们把它封锁了。我们把它封锁了。而且我，就很好奇想问凯特。就像，凯特，你长期以来的伴侣知道。
about this was taking pictures on the set. When did you find out? I need a follow-up question with Kate now. Well, yeah. Because we didn't know. We would never, we, I didn't tell anyone. I didn't tell anyone. Kate, certainly. Oscar. Ellie? Ellie. Ellie didn't tell anyone? We had dinner with Ellie. We're like, how's it going. She's like, oh, you know. What? We had that. She didn't say a word. That's how tight this community is. Yeah. Well, everyone in their- Well, I guess except for the one person who told us. about Oscar. I know. Well, everyone who knew was very protective of it.
这件事还在片场拍过照。你是什么时候知道的？我现在需要跟进问凯特一个问题。好吧，是的。因为我们不知道。我们绝不会，我们，我没有告诉任何人。我没有告诉任何人。凯特，当然。奥斯卡。埃莉？埃莉。埃莉没有告诉任何人吗？我们和埃莉吃过晚饭。我们问，进展如何。她说，哦，你知道的。什么？我们有那个。她一句话也没说。这就是这个社区的紧密程度。好吧，大家在——好吧，我想除了那个把奥斯卡的事告诉我们的人之外。我知道。好吧，所有知道的人都对此守口如瓶。
Yes. And then ultimately, you know, a reporter found out, I am not surprised, though, because it's such a huge secret to keep for so long. And then they're filming at Universal Studios. We'll get to it. But there's, like, tour buses of people that go through there. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。然后最终，你知道，一个记者发现了，不过我一点也不感到意外，因为要保守这么大的秘密这么久太难了。然后他们还在环球影城（Universal Studios）拍摄。我们会讲到。但是，有那种观光旅游巴士的人会穿过那里。对。对。
I mean, there's so many people who could have seen Oscar at Universal Studios. It's a huge place. Yes. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we are going to talk all about the paper. Yep. All right, we're back. And the paper opens with words on a screen.
我的意思是，有那么多人在环球影城看到过奥斯卡。那是个巨大的地方。是的。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？然后当我们回来时，我们将讨论所有关于《办公室》的事情。对。好吧，我们回来了。《办公室》以屏幕上的文字开场。
Yeah. It's a title card and there's a message. The message says, in 2005, a documentary crew started filming at a paper company in Scranton, Pennsylvania. They followed the workers in an average office dealing with new rules of workplace behavior and the ups and downs of their personal lives. And then it says, 20 years later, they returned. And the first thing the documentary crew, who's been gone for 20 years, shows us is the Scranton Business Park. The exterior of our building. That's right. It's the parking lot.
对。这是一个片头标题，上面有一条信息。信息写着：2005年，一个纪录片摄制组开始在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的一家纸业公司进行拍摄。他们追踪记录了一家普通办公室里的员工，看他们如何应对职场行为的新规则以及个人生活的起起落落。然后它写道：20年他们回来了。而离开20年的纪录片摄制组给我们展示的第一件事，就是斯克兰顿商业园。我们大楼的外景。没错。就是停车场。
lot. There are four business signs listed. A little bit of a foreshadowing here. The businesses listed are Vance Refrigeration, one and done laser eye surgery and tattoo removal, Rubens, and Cavala. Yeah. And now the camera crew starts to push into those doors that we know, those glass doors. One background catch here as we scan the parking lot, everything looks the same except there are now electric car chargers. I didn't even notice that. Yeah. Oh, I love that detail.
停车场。上面列出了四块商业招牌。这里有点像个伏笔。列出的企业有：万斯冷冻、一劳永逸激光视力矫正与文身清除、鲁本斯以及卡瓦拉。对。现在摄像机开始推向那些我们熟悉的门，那些玻璃门。在我们扫视停车场时，有一个背景细节：一切看起来都一样，除了现在多了电动汽车充电桩。我甚至都没注意到这一点。对。哦，我太喜欢这个细节了。
Yeah, we are going to go inside and guess where we start. This was such a surprise, and I loved it so much. We're at Vance Refrigeration, and we are warmly greeted by Bob Vance. Bobby Ray Schaefer. Mm-hmm. Bobby Ray does such a great job. Bob Vance is going to have a talking head. He says, hey, Dundra Mifflin's been gone.
对，我们要进去了，猜猜我们在哪开始的。这真是个惊喜，我太喜欢了。我们在万斯冷冻，鲍勃·万斯热情地迎了上来。鲍比·雷·谢弗。嗯哼。鲍比·雷表现得太棒了。鲍勃·万斯要有一个访谈镜头了。他说，嘿，邓德米夫林已经离开好一阵子了。
for a while. Phyllis and Stanley keep in touch. They've both got the same kind of dog, a schnoodle. Yeah. And he says, you know, the one and done guys are less drama. And you're kind of like, who are the one and done guys? Yeah, what's one and done? Well, we go down the hall to where the Dundra Mifflin offices were. Yeah, we go past the elevator and we open that door. And first of all, there's no carpeting. It's now hardwood floors. Oh, I didn't notice that. Yeah. Reception desk is completely different. It's like metal and shiny. Yeah, it has like, what do you, like LED lights on it. Yeah. Yeah. It's very modern. Very modern, very slick looking. Yes. And yeah, it's a laser eye company and laser tattoo removal. Yes. So the documentary crew clocks this and then they go back to talk to Bob. Yeah. He's going to get on his computer and he's going to explain that Dunder Mithelam was purchased in two. 2019 by a company called Enervate in Ohio, they asked if Phyllis wanted to leave and move to Toledo, go with the company. And Phyllis was like, yeah, right, forget it. She's like, leave Scranton? Yeah. No. I have two background catches for my folks that love a background catch. Bob Vance has a post-it note on his computer. It's on the top left corner. It's orange. And it says in handwriting, 10% discount only on fridges, not labor. Oh. So you're not going to get a discount on labor. Also, the Chamber of Commerce website is on the screen. If you go to it, because I did, it is not an active website. Oh. They didn't set up faky website. Got it. Here's something I thought of. If Dundermifflin was sold in 2019, that means it was sold before the pandemic. Oh. So Dwight never had to deal with like COVID rules.
菲利斯和斯坦利保持着联系。他们都养了同一种狗，一种雪纳瑞犬。对。他说，你知道，一劳永逸那些家伙戏剧性少一些。你会有点纳闷，一劳永逸的家伙是谁？对，什么是一劳永逸？好吧，我们顺着走廊走到以前的邓德米夫林办公室。对，我们走过电梯，打开了那扇门。首先，没有地毯了。现在是硬木地板。哦，我没注意到这个。对。前台完全变了。看起来像金属的，亮闪闪的。对，上面还有什么，比如LED灯。对。对。非常现代。非常现代，看起来非常时髦。是的。纪录片摄制组注意到了这一点，然后他们回去找鲍勃谈话。对。他坐到电脑前，解释说邓德米夫林在2019年被俄亥俄州一家名为“能量激活”的公司收购了，他们问菲利斯愿不愿意离开并搬到托莱多，跟着公司走。菲利斯当时就想，得了吧，门儿都没有。她心想，离开斯克兰顿？才不呢。对于喜欢找背景彩蛋的听众，我有两个背景彩蛋。鲍勃·万斯的电脑上有一张便利贴。在左上角。是橙色的。上面手写着：10%折扣仅限冰箱，不含人工费。哦。所以你在人工费上是得不到折扣的。此外，屏幕上还有商会网站。如果你访问它，因为我访问过，它不是一个活跃的网站。哦。他们没有做一个假的网站。明白了。我想到了这样一件事：如果邓德米夫林在2019年被出售，那就意味着它是在大流行之前出售的。哦。所以德怀特根本不用应付什么新冠规则。
Here's my question. Yes. Does Dwight still own the Scranton Park, though? Oh, does he still own the building? Yeah, because he bought the whole building. You're right. Yeah. We don't know the answer to that right now.
我的问题是。对。那德怀特现在还拥有斯克兰顿商业园吗？哦，他还拥有这栋大楼吗？对，因为他买下了整栋大楼。你说的对。对。我们现在还不知道答案。
We don't. Mm-mm. I secretly hope he does. Well, I just loved that the show opens with a familiar face. I love hearing that Stanley and Phyllis both have schnoodles. You know, I was just sort of on the edge of my face. I saw Bobby. I know. We did not know he was part of the show. We knew about Oscar, but I did not know about Bobby. Also, did you have to Google schnoodles because I did. No, I just assumed they were
我们不知道。嗯嗯。我暗自希望他买着。好吧，我只是很喜欢节目一开场就是一个熟悉的面孔。我很高兴听说斯坦利和菲利斯都养了雪纳瑞。你知道，我当时简直紧张得坐立难安。我看到了鲍比。我知道。我们不知道他是节目的一部分。我们知道奥斯卡的事，但不知道鲍比的事。还有，你是不是得去谷歌一下雪纳瑞，因为我查了。不，我只是以为它们是
like a schnauzer and a poodle. That's exactly what they are. I mean, it's like a Labradoodle is like a Labrador and a poodle. I guess it didn't click for me what a schnoodle was. I didn't know you could mix a schnauzer and a poodle. I didn't either. How does that work? I don't know and I don't want to think about it. Okay. But back to Bobby Ray for a second. So you guys, we did an AT&T commercial. It's out in the world now. You will have seen some of it. It's so good. It's so funny, lady. They're so fun. You did them as well. They've really gotten almost the entire cast. Yeah. Well, we were on set one day, and we were just chatting. I was asking him how his life is. He has a very peaceful existence on this nice big property in West Virginia, and we exchange phone
像雪纳瑞和贵宾犬的结合。它们确实就是这样。我的意思是，就像拉布拉多贵宾犬是拉布拉多和贵宾犬一样。我猜我当时没反应过来雪纳瑞是什么。我不知道雪纳瑞和贵宾犬还能串种。我也不知道。那是怎么做到的？我不知道，也不想去想它。好吧。不过我们还是说回鲍比·雷吧。伙计们，我们拍了一个AT&T的广告。现在已经在播了。你们应该已经看过一部分了。太棒了。太搞笑了，蕾迪。他们太有趣了。你们也拍了。他们几乎把整个演员阵容都请齐了。对。好吧，有一天我们在片场，我们就在闲聊。我问他最近过得怎么样。他在西弗吉尼亚州一个漂亮的大庄园里过着非常平静的生活，我们交换了电话
numbers. And when I watched this, I was like, oh my gosh, Bobby Ray. was in it and didn't even tell me. There you go. There you go. So I texted him and I was like, can you please share with us what it was like to be on the paper? And he sent us in this lovely audio clip.
号码。当我看到这个时，我在想，哦天哪，鲍比·雷居然参演了，甚至都没有告诉我。就是这样。就是这样。所以我给他发短信说，你能跟我们分享一下参与这档关于纸业的节目录制是什么感觉吗？他给我们发来了这段可爱的音频剪辑。
Let's hear it. Hello to the office ladies, Angela and Jenna. And your loyal listeners, this is Bobby Ray Schaefer, aka Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration. I'm pleased to join you today
我们听听看。向《办公室女士》的安吉拉和珍娜问好。还有你们的忠实听众，我是鲍比·雷·谢弗，也就是万斯冷冻的鲍勃·万斯。很高兴今天能加入你们
to talk about my experience filming the new TV show, The Paper. There I was in my house on the hill, in the woods, in West Virginia, minding my own business. And I was working on my autobiography, which I'm sure the listeners will delight in the title, which is what line of work are you in Bob? Of course, it's about all the jobs that I had in my career, including the most famous and loved of the mall, the office, thanks to the greatest fans ever. So I receive an email in my inbox one morning,
来聊聊我参与拍摄新电视剧《纸业公司》的经历。当时我在西弗吉尼亚州树林里山上的房子里，安分守己地过着自己的日子。我当时正在写我的自传，我确信听众一定会喜欢它的书名，那就是：鲍勃，你是做什么工作的？当然，这本书写的是我职业生涯中做过的所有工作，包括其中最著名、最受喜爱的《办公室》，多亏了史上最棒的粉丝们。所以有一天早晨，我的收件箱里收到了一封电子邮件，
and I opened it up, and it's from Hollywood. Would I be interested? Would I be available for a new Greg Daniels project? Well, there's only one answer to that, and it is, of course, yes. So I send back my availability is total. And then I had to wait for a while. You know how that goes, ladies. And at the time, I had thought when I left L.A.
我打开一看，是好莱坞发来的。我有兴趣吗？我有时间参与格雷格·丹尼尔斯的新项目吗？好吧，答案只有一个，那就是：当然有。于是我回复说我有绝对的空档。然后我就得等上一段时间了。女士们，你们知道那是怎么回事。当时我想，当我离开洛杉矶
after 40 years of grinding, that I would never go back. But, of course, as I told the producer who contacted me, I've never said no to Greg Daniels, and I'm not going to start now. So after about a month of, is it going to happen, is it not going to happen? And I found myself right back in the old mindset of it is, it isn't, it is, it is. And, you know, that's torture for an actor. But after not having to go through it for a while, it was kind of fun to be back in it to tell you the truth. And the deal was closed.
经历了40年的打拼之后，我再也不会回去了。但是，正如我对联系我的制片人所说的那样，我从来没有拒绝过格雷格·丹尼尔斯，现在也不会开始拒绝。所以在经历了一个月的“到底会不会发生”、“到底会不会发生”之后，我又回到了那种患得患失、琢磨不定的老心态里。你知道，这对演员来说简直就是折磨。但在有一段时间不用经历这种煎熬之后，说实话，重新回到这种状态感觉还挺有意思的。最后合同敲定了，
The arrangements were made, and I found myself on a big old jet plane to the coast. I went to the set the next morning, and I'd say that was the biggest difference in the office and the paper is that being on the universal lot. When I would walk out of my trailer, you know, the tour carts would come rolling by and all the people were waving and staring and yelling. And that was a new dimension to filming. But anyway, it was fantastic to be back in the Vance Refrigeration Office. As you know, details are key on the office and they are too on the paper because it was a perfect replica right down to a secretary and the whole. office you know i i really knew then what deja vu felt like i mean you know i'd been there before but it was delightful to see all the uh there were many of the crew members and the key guy of course
各项安排妥当，我发现自己坐上了飞往海岸的大型喷气式客机。第二天早上我去了片场，我要说的是，《办公室》和《纸业公司》最大的区别在于，《纸业公司》是在环球影城片场拍摄的。当我走出我的休息车时，你知道的，观光游览车会从旁边缓缓开过，所有的人都在挥手、盯着看、大喊大叫。这给拍摄带来了一个新的维度。不过不管怎样，能回到万斯冷冻办公室真是太棒了。如你所知，《办公室》里的细节至关重要，《纸业公司》里也是如此，因为它是一个完美的复制品，甚至连前台秘书和整个办公室都一模一样。你知道，我当时真的感受到了什么是似曾相识。我的意思是，你知道的，我以前去过那里，但很高兴能看到所有的……呃，有许多剧组人员，当然还有除了丹尼尔斯先生之外的关键人物，
other than mr daniels was sergio our caterer and he was there and it was a delight to see him and veda the script supervisor and dave rogers the editor and so it was like old home we And it was really just a wonderful feeling to be back involved with those great people, so talented. And Greg was directing the pilot. And so I got to spend some quality time with him. And he had written a very smart, funny open. I hope you'll all enjoy it. And the main reason I did it, of course, other than, you know, it was Greg.
那就是我们的餐饮主管塞尔吉奥，他也在那里，看到他真是太高兴了；还有剧本主管维达，以及剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，所以这感觉就像是故地重游。能够再次与这些才华横溢的伟大人们共事，真的是一种美妙的感觉。而且格雷格在执导试播集。所以我得以和他度过了一些美好的时光。他写了一个非常聪明、搞笑的开场。我希望你们大家都会喜欢。我参演的主要原因，当然除了因为那是格雷格之外，
And it's the historical link with the office. As you know, as many of you know, I've been doing a lot. lot of fan shows. And I have to say, I'll say it again, we do have the greatest fans in television show history. And I want to thank you all very much for making us feel so treasured and cherished. It's really, truly a great honor. And it's, it's been a blessing to be able to make people happy with just a photo and a signature. And you gave me that. So office ladies, you're kicking butt, taking names, keep it up. Love you very much, and I'll see you.
还有它与《办公室》的历史渊源。如你所知，正如你们许多人所知，我一直在参加很多粉丝见面会。我必须说，我还是要再说一遍，我们确实拥有电视史上最棒的粉丝。我要非常感谢你们大家让我们感到如此被珍视和宠爱。这真的是一个巨大的荣誉。能够只凭一张照片和一个签名就能给人们带来快乐，这真是一种福气。你们给了我这一切。所以，《办公室》的女士们，你们在全力以赴，干得漂亮，继续保持。非常爱你们，回头见。
Bye-bye. Oh, that's not great. So great. I just loved all of that. And I texted him, thank you so much from the two of us. And he said, well, Ange, thank you and know that I forgive you for spitting on me. And I said, wait, what are you talking about? When did I spit on you?
拜拜。哦，太棒了。真的太棒了。我太喜欢所有这些了。我给他发短信，代表我们俩向他表示万分感谢。他说：“好了，安吉，谢谢你，而且你知道我原谅你朝我吐口水的事了。”我说：“等等，你在说什么？我什么时候朝你吐口水了？”
I'm so sorry. I guess I'm a hot mess. I thought maybe I spit on him on the AT&D commercial. Okay. And he wrote back and he said, ha, ha, fun run. I made a remark about the dead cat. It was a deleted scene. Oh, my gosh.
我很抱歉。我想我当时一定是糊涂了。我以为我是在拍AT&T广告时朝他吐口水了。好吧。他回信说：“哈哈，趣味赛跑。我当时开了一个关于死猫的玩笑。那是一个被删掉的镜头。”哦，天哪。
And I was just teasing. So now I want to go back to Fun Run deleted scenes and be like, I totally forgot that scene. Well, Greg told me that they went back to our old lot and they restored the Scranton Business Sign Park for that. opening, establishing shot, and he said that on that day, some fans were there. And they came and took photos. He was like, they got really lucky because, you know, that sign is not usually there on the building. He said it was just kind of cool to see it there again. But like Bobby said, the vance refrigeration and the eye center and the elevator, all of that, they completely rebuilt on a soundstage at the Universal lot because that's where they shot the paper was on a
我当时只是在开玩笑。所以现在我想回去看看《趣味赛跑》被删掉的镜头，然后心想：我完全忘了还有那一幕。好吧，格雷格告诉我，为了那个开场建立镜头，他们回到了我们老旧的片场，恢复了斯克兰顿商业标志公园的原貌。他说那天有一些粉丝在那里。他们过来拍了照片。他说他们真的非常幸运，因为你知道，那个标志通常不在那栋大楼上。他说看到它重新出现在那里感觉挺酷的。但就像鲍比说的，万斯冷冻、眼科中心和电梯，所有这些都是他们在环球影城片场的摄影棚里完全重建的，因为《纸业公司》就是在环球影城的摄影棚里拍摄的。
soundstage at the Universal lot. That's right. And we went and visited there. And, you know, we were walking to our cars at the end of the day. Greg was so sweet. He walked us out after our visit. We're standing by the cars. And one of those buses went by. Yeah, that Bobby talked about. Yeah. It's like an open air bus with a bunch of visitors who are coming to Universal Studios. You pay for this past. You get the tour of the whole back lot. And there we were standing there. and Greg literally was like, get down, look at us, dive behind like a dumpster. We literally dove behind a dumpster because we did not want people to see us there. We were afraid.
没错。我们去那里参观过。而且，你知道，我们在一天结束时正走向我们的汽车。格雷格太贴心了。我们参观完后，他亲自送我们出来。我们站在汽车旁边，其中一辆观光车开了过去。对，就是鲍比说的那辆。对。那就像是一辆露天巴士，上面坐着一群来环球影城参观的游客。你买张通票，就能参观整个外景地。当时我们就站在那儿，
With Greg. Yes, that it would, because there were the rumors that the paper was happening. Yeah. And we, yes. Yeah. But I have to say, hearing now that people took pictures of that Scranton Park sign at our old set. Yeah. Guys, zoom in. I bet you have laser one and done.
格雷格简直就像是说：“趴下，看着我们，快躲到垃圾桶后面。”我们真的扑通一声躲到了垃圾桶后面，因为我们不想让别人看到我们在那儿。我们当时有点害怕。
You probably do. Yeah. Well, now that our documentary crew has figured out that Dunder Mitham was bought by Enervate, we're going to go to Enervate. To Toledo. Yes, to the Truth Teller Tower. And we go upstairs and we're going to see a bunch of workers in these, like, glass walled cubicles. And one of them is shaving. He's got an electric shaver, and he's reclining, kind of shaving. He's getting the side eye from the person in the cubicle next to him. Shout out to Stephen Sox, who played the man shaving his face. You might recognize that name because we have talked about him and his wife, Lori, for years. They were the stand-in team on the office.
跟格雷格一起。是的，因为这会……因为当时有传言说《纸业公司》要拍了。对。我们，是的。对。但我必须得说，现在听到人们在我们的老片场拍下了那个斯克兰顿公园标志的照片。对。伙计们，放大看看。我敢说你们能看到“一劳永逸激光矫正”。
They both had cameos on the office, and I was so tickled to see him on the paper. Yes, lady, when we visited, we saw both Stephen and Lori, and it was so cool, but I had no idea that he had a cameo. Neither did I. Because everybody locked it up. So when we watched this, I texted him about working on the paper. I asked him how him and Lori came to work on the paper, what it was like working on the show, what it was like to do this cameo. And he sent us the most lovely message, just like Bobby Ray. Everyone has just been so wonderful. You got to hear it. Lori and I both got to work on the paper, and the pilot episode was really a thrill. I mean, somehow we were both able to work on the office for all those years, and we made so many memories.
你们可能真的能看到。好吧，既然我们的纪录片摄制组已经弄清楚了邓德米夫林被能量激活公司收购了，我们要去能量激活了。去托莱多。是的，去“真理讲述者之塔”。我们走上楼去，会看到一群工人坐在这些像玻璃墙隔出来的格子里。其中一个人正在刮胡子。他拿着一个电动剃须刀，半躺着刮胡子。他旁边格子里的那个人正斜眼看着他。向扮演刮胡子男子的斯蒂芬·索克斯致敬。你可能对这个名字很熟悉，因为我们多年来一直谈论他和他的妻子洛里。他们是《办公室》里的替身演员团队。
And as soon as we found out about there even being a true office spinoff, we reached out to Greg Daniels, who is just so kind and just absolutely brilliant. and somehow we got to work on this brand new show. Well, one day I had a break from filming and I walked over to one of the other stages we were using and I saw the outside of a set that had just been built and from the outside, a set just looks like wood and nails and a door here and there
他们俩都在《办公室》里客串过，看到他出现在《纸业公司》里我真是高兴极了。是的，蕾迪，当我们去参观时，我们见到了斯蒂芬和洛里，这太酷了，但我根本不知道他有过客串演出。我也不知道。因为大家都保密得死死的。所以当我们看这个的时候，我给他发了短信，问他关于在《纸业公司》工作的事。我问他他和洛里是怎么去《纸业公司》工作的，在节目组工作是什么感觉，客串演出是什么体验。他给我们发来了一条无比温馨的信息，就像鲍比·雷一样。每个人都太棒了。你们一定要听听看。洛里和我都参与了《纸业公司》的工作，试播集真的让人非常激动。我的意思是，不知怎的，我们俩居然都能在《办公室》工作那么多年，我们留下了那么多的回忆。
and it's not until you open the door and step inside that the set is revealed. There was no one else, not a single person on stage. And so I was all alone. And I was curious about what we might shoot the next few days. You know, it could have been a restaurant or an apartment or whatever. So I opened one of the doors and it was the office's elevator lobby. I had entered that door that was a stairwell door next to Bob Vance's glass door. And I was instantly taken back to the old Chandler Valley Studios in Van Nuys.
而且一听说真的要拍《办公室》的衍生剧，我们就联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他不仅人超级好，而且绝对是个天才，不知怎么的，我们居然能参与到这部全新的剧集中来。好吧，有一天我拍戏间隙休息，我走到我们正在使用的另一个片场，我看到了一处刚搭建好的布景的外观。从外面看，布景看起来只是一些木头和钉子，这里一扇门，那里一扇门，
It was shocking and emotional, actually. I walked up to the elevator and so many memories flooded my brain, and I thought of one of the most vivid memories on the show. It was Steve Carell's last day and specifically Steve's last scene. The scene was when Michael says goodbye to the office. office and he walks to the elevator and exits the building. The day before Greg had asked me to wear a suit and so he put me in the scene. Me and a mail courier walk out of the elevator as Michael walks in on Steve's last take, I watched the character Michael Scott enter the elevator
直到你打开门走进去，布景才会展现在眼前。里面空无一人，片场里连一个人都没有。所以我独自一人。我对我们接下来几天要拍摄的内容很好奇。你知道，那可能是一家餐厅、一间公寓或者别的什么。所以我打开了一扇门，那是办公室的电梯大厅。我走进了那扇门，那是鲍勃·万斯玻璃门旁边的楼梯间门。我瞬间被拉回了范奈斯的钱德勒谷老片场。
and the door is closed and then after the scene ended, the doors opened and the actor Steve Karell stepped out. It really was just him and I in the lobby at that point, and I couldn't help myself, and I just gave him a big hug. Well, here I was, back in that space, and I had goosebumps. I saw Bob Bance's office, and then I walked toward the Dunder Mifflin office, and it was a laser hair removal place, so it was, Dunder Mifflin was gone. And what I felt at that moment was just closure. Life moves on and art shows us in amazing ways that life has changed. I got to stand there in that moment full of gratitude for all that the office meant to me.
门关上了，接着场景结束后，门又打开了，演员史蒂夫·卡瑞尔走了出来。那时大厅里真的只有我和他，我情不自禁地给了他一个大大的拥抱。好吧，当时我又回到了那个空间，起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。我看到了鲍勃·班斯的办公室，然后我走向邓德米夫林办公室，结果那里成了一个激光脱毛的地方，所以，邓德米夫林已经消失了。我在那一刻感受到的只有释怀。生活在继续，艺术以惊人的方式向我们展示了生活已经发生了变化。那一刻，我怀着对邓德米夫林对我而言的一切的感激之情站在那里。
And then in that same breath, I got to pivot to this brand new show. And then like the next day they asked me if I could come in and work with. with the talented Tim Key in one of the opening scenes of the pilot. Just an incredible experience that I will never forget. That is so powerful. Well, I cried the first time I listened to that. Yeah. Because he's right about what art can show us.
紧接着，我转而谈到了这部全新的剧集。然后就像第二天一样，他们问我能不能来和才华横溢的蒂姆·基一起参与试播集开场戏之一的拍摄。这真的是一次我永远不会忘记的不可思议的经历。这太有力量了。好吧，我第一次听的时候都哭了。是的。因为他说得很对，艺术能向我们展示什么。
And I just can't imagine what it was like. Like, it feels like time travel. If I could open a door and be standing in that elevator bay again, And I didn't know that story that he had that moment with Steve. Yeah. And then now he is there again all these years later in that same elevator bay. And, yeah, I thought Stephen said it all so well. Yeah.
我简直无法想象那是什么感觉。就像是在进行时间旅行。如果我能打开一门，再次站在那个电梯间里……我以前并不知道他和史蒂夫有过那样的一刻。是的。然后现在多年后他又回到了那个同样的电梯间，是的，我觉得斯蒂芬把这一切都表达得太好了。是的。
I felt everything that he shared. You're a little teary. I, you know, yeah, it makes me so excited for this group of people. I just hope that this show gets to give them what the office gave us. Yeah. All right. Well, now we are going to cut to a talking head of Ken. Ken is played by Tim Key.
我感同身受他分享的一切。你有点想哭了。我，你知道，是的，这让我对这群人感到无比兴奋。我只希望这部剧能给他们带来邓德米夫林带给我们的东西。是的。好了，现在我们要切到一个关于肯的采访特写。肯由蒂姆·基扮演。
He is British. He is the head of strategy for the corporate offices at Enervate. And he's going to explain to us what Enervate does. Let's listen. Enovate sells products made out of paper. So that might be office supplies. There might be janitorial paper, which is toilet tissue, toilet seat protectors, and local newspapers. And that is in order of quality.
他是英国人。他是恩内韦特公司企业办公室的战略主管。他要向我们解释恩内韦特公司是做什么的。我们来听听。恩诺维特公司销售用纸制造的产品。所以那可能是办公用品。可能是清洁用纸，比如卫生纸、马桶垫圈和当地报纸。这是按质量高低排列的。
I loved at the very end when he says, in order of quality, he thinks he's being funny. And he has this little smirk look to camera, and it just cracked me up. Now he's going to take us on the tour of the offices. He explains that the corporate office. offices are on the eighth floor. He's going to take us up to the ninth floor. This reminded me of our pilot where Michael Scott is taking you on a tour of Dunder Mifflin because he starts introducing everybody. Yep. We find out that the ninth floor is home to Softie's toilet paper. And when he opens the door, by the way, this is when we get our first glimpse of the set. And it is huge.
我很喜欢最后他说“按质量高低排列”的时候，他觉得自己很搞笑。他对着镜头露出了那种得意的微笑，真的把我逗笑了。现在他要带我们参观办公室。他解释说公司办公室在八楼。他要带我们去九楼。这让我想起了我们的试播集，迈克尔·斯科特带着你参观邓德米夫林，因为他开始给大家做介绍。是的。我们发现九楼是“Softie's”卫生纸的所在地。当他打开门时，顺便说一句，这是我们第一次瞥见这个布景。它太巨大了。
It's so vast. Yes. It is this big open space. But there are very few people. in it. Michael Comyn told me that this scene was the very first scene they shot of the paper. Oh, really? Yes. Aw. Well, you know, as Ken walks through, he's greeting his toilet kings and one queen, who I think has a little bit of an Angela Martin vibe. She's got that ponytail pulled back tight. And I love the throwaway snarky comment, Ken said as he walked past her. He says, scrunchy, no harm in it. Because she has her hair and a scrunchy. It was just, a really funny throwaway line. Well, scrunchy gal, aka Toilet Queen, is our first writer performer. She is a character that we're going to see at Softies named Kimberly, and she is played by Mo Welch.
它太辽阔了。是的。这是一个开阔的大空间。但里面的人很少。迈克尔·科明告诉我说这场戏是他们拍这部剧的第一个场景。哦，真的吗？是的。啊。嗯，你知道，当肯走过时，他在向他的卫生纸之王和女王打招呼，我觉得那位女王有点安吉拉·马丁的风范。她把马尾辫扎得紧紧的。我喜欢肯走过她时顺口说的一句讽刺的话。他说：“发圈，这没什么不好的。”因为她把头发扎在了发圈里。这真是一句非常搞笑的随性台词。好吧，发圈女，也就是卫生纸女王，是我们的第一位编剧兼演员。她是一个我们将在Softies见到的角色，名叫金伯利，由莫·韦尔奇饰演。
Ken continues now to show us the rest of the Softies side of the office. There's a lot of old artwork and logos, and then he takes us to a gong that they hit whenever a sale is made. I have to imagine that's going to drive everyone crazy if you work there. And this is when he introduces us to what's on the other side of the office, which is the local newspaper, the Toledo Truth Teller. Yes. We find out that this entire building... Which is a big building.
肯接着带我们参观Softies办公室的其余部分。有很多旧的艺术品和标志，然后他带我们去看了一个每当达成销售时就会敲响的锣。我猜如果你在那儿工作，这会把每个人都逼疯的。接着他向我们介绍了办公室另一侧的东西，也就是当地报纸《托莱多真理报》。是的。我们发现整栋大楼……这是一栋大楼。
Yes. It used to house the newspaper with a staff of like a thousand. And now they're just like half of this floor and there's like seven of them. Then we flash back to 1971. Yeah, we're going to watch a little black and white... documentary. That's the year I was born. Guys, we did have color TV in 1971. I am not that old. I am 54. You're so right. It made me laugh. Anyway. I think we just needed to differentiate between our current day story and this like documentary. You're so right. Anyway, I'm sure that's exactly why they're
是的。这里曾经是报社所在地，员工大约有一千人。而现在他们只占了这个楼层的一半，大约只有七个人。然后我们闪回到1971年。是的，我们要看一小段黑白纪录片。那是我出生的年份。伙计们，我们在1971年确实有彩色电视。我没有那么老。我54岁了。你说得太对了。这把我逗笑了。不管怎样。我想我们只是需要区分一下我们当下的故事和这个类似纪录片的画面。你说得太对了。不管怎样，我确信这正是他们
did it, but it did crack me up. Yeah, so we're watching this old documentary, and it's being hosted by John Stack, the publisher of the Toledo Truth Teller, and we're seeing our same set, but now it is just filled with like wall-to-wall people. John Stack is played by Tracy Let's lady, lady. Oh, your theater nerd heart went into overdrive. You were like, Angela. Angela. Tracy Letts. Multiple Tony Award winner. He wrote August to Osage County.
这么做的原因，但确实把我逗乐了。是的，所以我们正在看这部旧纪录片，由《托莱多真理报》的出版商约翰·斯塔克主持，我们看到了同样的布景，但现在里面挤满了人。约翰·斯塔克由特雷西·莱茨饰演，天呐，天呐。哦，你的戏剧书呆子之心彻底沸腾了。你当时就像是，安吉拉。安吉拉。特雷西·莱茨。托尼奖多次获得者。他写了《八月：奥色治郡》。
He won a Tony for playing George in the revival of Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf? I saw it. I saw all of it. I went to Chicago to see his play Superior Donuts at Steppenwolf. And Lady, afterwards, I got to go out and have drinks with him. Wow. Did you keep your cool? Did you say anything ridiculous?
他因为在复排版的《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫》中饰演乔治而获得托尼奖。我看过。我都看过。我去了芝加哥去斯滕沃夫剧院看他的剧《上等甜甜圈》。而且，天呐，演出结束后我还和她一起去喝了酒。哇。你保持冷静了吗？你说什么荒谬的话了吗？
I barely spoke. That's smart. That's smart. I was so nervous. Yes, yes. So I asked Michael Coleman, I was like, how did you get Tracy Letts on the show? And Michael Coleman was like as big of a nerd about him as I was. And he said he was my first choice.
我几乎没怎么说话。这很明智。这很明智。我太紧张了。是的，是的。所以我问迈克尔·科曼，我说你是怎么请到特雷西·莱茨来演这部剧的？迈克尔·科曼对他的崇拜程度跟我一样像个书呆子。他说他是我心中的首选。
So they just reached out. And he said yes. And Michael was like I was genuinely thrilled. Well, now the scene that's going to come at the end makes perfect sense to me. Uh-huh. We'll get to that. We'll get to it. Because of Michael's love of him.
所以他们就联系了他。而他答应了。迈克尔说我当时真的激动坏了。好吧，现在最后要播出的那个场景对我来说就完全合情合理了。嗯哼。我们一会儿会讲到。我们会讲到的。因为迈克尔太喜欢他了。
Well, he absolutely adores him. He said they actually shot a ton of stuff with him, and he really hopes that they're going to be able to keep weaving this old, quote-unquote, documentary. From 1971. In black and white. Exactly. But this was all just to show us, to give us a visual of, like, what this used to be and what it is now. Yes. Just the juxtaposition of this lively, hustling.
好吧，他简直太崇拜他了。他说他们其实拍了大量关于他的素材，他真的希望他们能继续将这个旧的，所谓“纪录片”的元素融入其中。从1971年开始。黑白的。没错。但这其实只是为了向我们展示，给我们一个直观的视觉感受，看看这里过去是什么样，现在又是什么样。是的。就是这种充满活力、忙忙碌碌的繁华报社与现状的对比。
bustle and bustle thriving newspaper. And now it's like in the same office space as a toilet paper and toilet seat cover company. And it's not even the major earner. Yeah. So we cut back to present day. We're going to meet our first character from the truth teller. And it's mayor. She's a young woman. She's sitting at her desk. Ding, ding, ding. We have our first adorable coffee mug siding. Oh, what is it? Everyone else has had a paper coffee. cup, and Maher's coffee mug is adorable. It's banana-themed. It's a bunch of little bananas, and they're all wearing little black-rimmed glasses. What? I missed it. I just loved it. And you guys, I'm going to give you a little sprinkle of what's on everyone's desk as we go through. Mare's desk is very
生机勃勃、蒸蒸日上的报社。而现在它居然和一家卫生纸及马桶垫圈公司挤在同一个办公空间里。而且它甚至都不是主要的盈利点。是的。所以我们切回现代。我们要认识《真理报》的第一个角色。她叫梅尔。她是个年轻女性。她坐在办公桌前。叮，叮，叮。我们看到了第一个可爱的咖啡马克杯。哦，是什么样的？其他人都用纸质咖啡杯，而梅尔的咖啡杯太可爱了。是香蕉主题的。是一串小香蕉，它们都戴着黑框小眼镜。什么？我错过了。我只是太喜欢了。然后，伙计们，我要在讲解的过程中给你们透露一点每个人桌上的东西。梅尔的桌子非常
simple. There's an article that she has had framed, probably that she wrote, we're guessing, and a personal photo and some hand sanitizer. Well, we are going to learn that her job is compositor. And here's what she does. just goes to the AP, she pulls stories that are in their subscription price point. Clearly, they haven't sprung for the best stories. No. And she just drags the articles into this, like, what would you call it? Yeah. Plops them in there, and then it formats them, and then voila. Yeah. Mayor is played by actress Chelsea Fry. We got to meet her. We interviewed her. If you didn't hear her interview, go back and listen to it, because it's amazing. I was absolutely blown away by her performance, I'm a little obsessed. She's so good. She makes so many great choices and you don't see
简单。有一篇她装裱起来的文章，可能是她写的，我们猜的，还有一张个人照片和一些洗手液。好吧，我们将会了解到她的工作是排版员。以下是她的工作内容。她只是去美联社，挑选那些在他们的订阅价格范围内的报道。显然，他们没有花大价钱买最好的报道。没有。她只是把文章拖到这个，你管这叫什么？对。把它们塞进去，然后排版，然后就好了。是的。梅尔由演员切尔西·弗赖饰演。我们见到了她。我们采访了她。如果你还没听她的采访，回去听一下，因为太棒了。她的表演彻底震撼了我，我有点着迷了。她太棒了。她做出了那么多出色的选择，而你根本看不出
her making them. Do you know what I mean? Yes. It feels so effortless. Yes. I told Greg, I'm obsessed with her. Yeah. She's so good. Well, now coming up, you guys, we have the opening credits. Yes. I just loved them. I love the opening credits. We've seen the first four episodes and I've watched the opening credits every time. I'm not skipping the opening credits. They're great. What they are, you guys, is sort of a montage of vintage scenes of people using newspaper for anything other than reading it. Yes. Then you do see some people reading it. But we end on a shot of the newspaper, and it has been used to line a bird cage. It's the character Nicole's Birdcage, and I guess the bird has peed and pooped on it because it's the liner of her bird cage, and she is scraping it into the
她在刻意表现。你知道我的意思吗？是的。感觉太自然了。是的。我告诉格雷格，我迷上她了。是的。她太棒了。好了，接下来，伙计们，我们要看片头字幕了。是的。我太喜欢了。我喜欢片头字幕。我们已经看了前四集，每一集我都看了片头字幕。我没有跳过片头字幕。它们太棒了。它们是什么呢，伙计们，基本上是一组合辑，展示人们用报纸做除了阅读之外的各种事情。是的。然后你确实看到了一些人在阅读它。但我们的结尾是一个报纸的镜头，它被用来铺鸟笼了。那是角色妮可的鸟笼，我猜那只鸟在上面撒尿拉屎了，因为它是她鸟笼的衬垫，而她正把它铲进
trash. Well, I love all of the images from this, but I also absolutely loved the theme song. It's very reminiscent of one we've grown to love. I think we should hear it. Lady, I hope that one day this cast is walking across the stage, getting an award to that song. I know. I really do. I just hope they get it all. Can you please tell us about this song? Because it's just so special.
垃圾桶里。好吧，我喜欢这里所有的画面，但我也极其喜欢这个主题曲。它非常让人想起我们日渐喜爱的那个旋律。我想我们应该听一下。天呐，我希望有一天这个剧组能走上舞台，伴随着这首歌领取奖项。我知道。我真的这么希望。我只希望他们能包揽一切。能请给我们讲讲这首歌吗？因为它太特别了。
It gave me, like, the chills, like one of the chills, like one. I hear the office one. And then, of course, I love the little callback to the very end piano keys. Well, Greg said that he did the same thing he'd done for the office in Parks and Rec in that he took submissions from a variety of composers. He asked a number of people, write me a song. And ultimately, he loved this one. It's by Nick Thornburn and Patrick Ford, but get this lady.
它让我起鸡皮疙瘩，就像那种鸡皮疙瘩，有一种……我听到办公室的那首了。然后，当然，我喜欢对最后钢琴键的那个小小的呼应。好吧，格雷格说他做了和《办公室》以及《公园与游憩》一样的事情，那就是他向各种各样的作曲家征集作品。他要求很多人：给我写一首歌。最终，他最喜欢这一首。这是由尼克·索恩伯恩和帕特里克·福特创作的，但听着，天呐。
After he picked the composition, he went to Bob Field and the Scrantones to record it live, They were the band from Boos Cruz, and they were also the musicians who played our theme song. That is so amazing. That is so full circle. And I feel like that's why it has a similar feel. Yes. Yeah. Love that.
在他选定这首曲子后，他找到了鲍勃·菲尔德和Scrantones乐队去现场录制，他们是Boos Cruz的乐队，也是演奏我们主题曲的乐手。这太神奇了。这真是一个完美的闭环。我觉得这就是为什么它有一种相似的熟悉感。是的。是的。太喜欢了。
Okay. So the episode is going to start with a talking head from mayor. She's going to tell us about their one resident reporter. The Real Deal reporter. His name is Barry. When they need accurate local sports coverage, that's who they go to. They cut over to Barry. he is asleep.
好的。这一集将从梅尔的采访特写开始。她将向我们介绍他们唯一的常驻记者。真正的硬核记者。他的名字叫巴里。当他们需要准确的当地体育报道时，找的就是他。镜头切到巴里。他在睡觉。
Yes, yes. He's an older gentleman who's been there a long time. He is played by Dwayne Shepard, Sr., and he's our one reporter. That's it. Well, now we are going to meet. Oh, my gosh. She's my fave. Talk about owning a scene.
是的，是的。他是一位在那儿工作了很久的老先生。他由老德韦恩·谢泼德饰演，他就是我们唯一的记者。就这些。好吧，现在我们要去见。哦，天呐。她是我的最爱。谈到如何掌控一个场景。
Ah, we're going to meet Esmeralda, played by Sabrina and Pachitori. You might remember her from season two of White Lotus. She plays the woman at the front desk who's like running the host. tell. Yes, she is incredible. And I just literally everything she says, I love her. I know. I have this whole thing where I go between Chelsea and Sabrina, and I'm obsessed with these two women on this show. Also, the moment we first met her, I felt like I was in a movie meeting someone. You mean when we met her in real life? In real life. Yes. Yes. Because she came in in this beautiful outfit, but she had just come from hair and makeup. Yeah. And so she had all these curlers in.
啊，我们要见埃斯梅拉达，由萨布丽娜·因帕奇托里饰演。你可能还记得她在《白莲花》第二季中的演出。她饰演前台接待员，有点像迎宾。是的，她太棒了。真的她说的每一句话，我都爱。我知道。我一直在切尔西和萨布丽娜之间反复横扫，我迷恋这部剧里的这两位女性。还有，我们第一次见到她的那一刻，我觉得自己就像在电影里偶遇某人一样。你是说我们在现实生活中见到她的时候？在现实生活中。是的。是的。因为她穿着一身漂亮的衣服进来，但她刚从美发化妆间出来。是的。所以她头发上还夹着好多卷发器。
her hair. She did, which is so funny because when she does her talking ahead in the episode, she's got clips in her hair. Yeah. So she's going to explain that she is in charge of TTT Online. I thought, when I first heard this, I thought she said Titty Online. Well, she does say that it's much more important, much more fun, and much sexier than the printed version of the newspaper. Because the print version is for people who just want to frame it if they're mentioned. But, the online version, they can go on and on and on. There's no space issues. So she's going to show us one of her recent articles. It's called, You Won't Believe How Much Ben Affleck tipped his limo driver. And her description of it is so funny. I think we need to hear it. There's so many pop-up
她确实夹着，这太搞笑了，因为当她在剧中做采访时，她头发上还夹着夹子。是的。所以她要解释说她负责TTTOline。我当时想，当我第一次听到这个时，我以为她说的是Titty Online。好吧，她确实说它比纸质版报纸重要得多、有趣得多，也性感得多。因为纸质版只适合那些如果被提及就想把它装裱起来的人。但是，网络版，他们可以没完没了地写下去。根本没有版面限制。所以她要向我们展示她最近的一篇文章。叫做，你绝对不敢相信本·阿弗莱克给他的豪华轿车司机小费给了多少。她对这篇文章的描述太搞笑了。我觉得我们得听听。有这么多的弹出
ads. Yes. At TTT Online, we have no space or length limitations. This is classic long form journalism. Here is one of my articles I'm particularly proud of. I don't know if you can see it. So you start reading it. Yes. And you get very curious. I'm scrolling. You go next. Oops. I hit an ad and I click here and I'm scrolling. And I'm learning a lot about the history of tipping. Like the first tip, what was that? Maybe a piece of cheese. And then you keep learning about colors of cars. There are so many colors. But it's not a waste of time. Because when you get to the end and you find out that the tips was $300. I mean, that's a lot. Lady, her article, it a little bit reminds me of me and you breaking something down. Right? Like, because we're
广告。是的。在TTTOline，我们没有任何空间或篇幅的限制。这就是经典的长篇新闻报道。这是我特别引以为傲的一篇文章。我不知道你们能不能看清楚。所以你开始阅读它。是的。然后你变得非常好奇。我往下滚动。你继续。哎呀。我点到了一个广告，然后我点这里，我继续滚动。我了解到了很多关于小费历史的知识。比如第一笔小费，那是什么？也许是一块奶酪。然后你继续了解汽车的颜色。有这么多的颜色。但这并不是在浪费时间。因为当你读到最后，发现小费是300美元。我的意思是，这真的很多。天呐，她的文章有点让我想起我和你剖析某些事情的样子。对吧？就像，因为我们在
going to take you on a deep dive of the history of tipping and the types of limos that existed in the world, just to eventually tell you that Ben Affleck tipped $300. Every time, we've watched this a few times now, and every time she gets to the part where she's like, what was the first tip? Maybe a piece of cheese. Makes me laugh every time. Every time. Well, while this talking head is going on, we get a real glimpse into Sabrina's office.
将带您深入探讨小费的历史以及世界上存在的各种豪华轿车，最终只是为了告诉您本·阿弗莱克给了300美元的小费。每一次，我们现在已经看了好几次了，每次当她讲到“第一笔小费是什么？也许是一块奶酪”时，我都会笑个不停。每次都是。好吧，在这个访谈镜头进行的同时，我们得以一窥萨布丽娜的办公室。
it might be one of the most amazingly chaotic, crazy, vivid offices, definitely on the set of the paper. There are so many great details. I'm going to list a few things I saw. First of all, there is a giant conch shell. Then a leopard printed swivel dust chair is what she sits on. There are gold little stars, like cut out, like construction paper looking gold stars. She's covered so many things in her office with gold stars. Multiple frames of just her covered with these little stars.
这可能是最令人惊叹的混乱、疯狂、生动的办公室之一，绝对是在《真相播报》的片场。有太多精彩的细节了。我来列举几个我看到的。首先，有一个巨大的海螺壳。然后她坐的是一张豹纹旋转防尘椅。有一些金色的星星，像是剪纸，看起来像手工纸做的小金星。她的办公室里有好多东西都贴上了金星。好几个相框里只有她被这些小星星覆盖着。
Her laptop has stars on them, but, lady, I thought of you. What? Did you clock how many lamps she has? No. She has a little tiny lamp with tripod legs with a little white square top. She has two big gold-based lamps with white rounded tops. Then she's got another like ye-oldy lamp with like the, pink shade with the tassels.
她的笔记本电脑上有星星，但是，女士，我想到了你。什么？你注意到她有多少盏灯了吗？没有。她有一盏带三脚架腿的小台灯，上面有一个白色的小方形灯罩。她有两盏带白色圆顶的大底座金灯。然后她还有另一盏老式台灯，带有粉红色的流苏灯罩。
God, I love a lamp. She's like you. I love a lamp. You, Sabrina, and Steve Curl's character on Anchorman. She also has a makeup mirror with a little makeup caddy. I clocked some half-burnt sage. She's been saging in there. Stacks of papers, cups holding pins, and scissors, a hairbrush,
天哪，我太喜欢台灯了。她就像你一样。我喜欢台灯。你、萨布丽娜以及史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在《王牌播音员》中饰演的角色。她还有一个带化妆盒的化妆镜。我注意到了一些烧了一半的鼠尾草。她在里面熏过鼠尾草。一堆堆的文件、装着笔和剪刀的杯子、一把发刷，
an open glass bottle of some type of soda, and some very sad-looking plants. Oh my gosh. She is me. Sad plants and lots of lamps. That could be my autobiography. There it is. Done. I'm buying that book. It writes itself. Well, obviously, this is the pilot episode. So we're learning about all these people. We've learned about Esmeralda. And now we're going to learn a little more about Mayor, who says that before she worked here, she was in the Army. And she did write for the military newspaper, stars, stripes. We got that paper when I lived overseas. Oh, yeah? Yeah, that's the paper I remember my dad reading growing up. Well, Esmeralda's going to walk around the office and introduce us to people. She's going to start with Nicole. Yeah, poor Nicole does not want to be on camera, and Esmeralda's going to make sure of it. She kind of like squeezes her face, and then it cuts to Nicole. We have a
一瓶打开的玻璃瓶装某种苏打水，还有一些看起来很可怜的植物。哦天哪。她就是我。可怜的植物和许多台灯。那可以是我的自传。就是这样。搞定。我要买那本书。它自己就会写出来。好吧，很明显，这是试播集。所以我们正在了解所有人。我们已经了解了埃斯梅拉达。现在我们要多了解一点梅尔，她说在她来这里工作之前，她曾在军队服役。她确实为军报《星条旗报》写过文章。我住在海外时我们看过那份报纸。哦，是吗？对，那是记忆中我爸从小看到大的报纸。好吧，埃斯梅拉达要在办公室四处走动，向我们介绍大家。她要从妮可开始。对，可怜的妮可不想上镜，而埃斯梅拉达要确保她不会上镜。她有点像是捏住她的脸，然后镜头切到了妮可。我们有一个
new talking head location. It's like a storage room. Yes, I loved it. I loved the visual of it. Behind her are all these old card catalog cabinets, you know, the tall ones that are made of wood and have the tiny little drawers. And then on either side of her are just shelves of files. Yes. And this is where we're going to get our like talking head confessions. Yes. You know what I thought? I thought of Leslie David Baker. Oh. And I thought of all the talking heads he sat in the background of. They made sure no one had to do that. Nobody had to do it this time. We're going to put you in a little. like a closet for these talking heads. That's right. No one in the background. Poor Leslie and Creed,
新的访谈镜头拍摄地点。它就像一个储藏室。是的，我很喜欢。我很喜欢它的视觉效果。在她身后是所有这些旧的卡片目录柜，你知道的，那种木质的高高的、带小抽屉的柜子。然后在她两侧只有一排排的文件。是的。这就是我们要进行访谈心声剖白的地方。是的。你知道我在想什么吗？我想到了莱斯利·大卫·贝克。哦。我想到了他作为背景坐在那里的所有访谈镜头。他们确保没有人必须那样做。这次没有人必须这么做。我们要把你放进一个小空间里。就像为这些访谈镜头准备的衣帽间。没错。背景里没有任何人。可怜的莱斯利和克里德，
Leslie the most, but those two were in so many. I know. The only talking heads we don't see in this card catalog file closet are the ones in some people's offices that have actual offices. Yes, correct. Well, Nicole is going to explain that she's in circulation. So she keeps track of subscribers. She also just talks about how maybe they generate revenue by maybe collecting and selling information on people who accept all the cookies on their website. She has a very funny line where she says, you could say we get more information from the readers than they get from us. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Nicole is played by Ramona Young, and we got to interview her when we visited. It got cut short because they needed her back on set, but you can listen to that interview.
莱斯利最多，但那两个人出现在太多集里了。我知道。在这个卡片目录文件衣帽间里，我们看不到的唯一访谈镜头是那些在某些人办公室里的镜头，因为他们有真正的办公室。是的，没错。好吧，妮可将解释说她在发行部。所以她负责追踪订阅者。她还谈到了他们如何通过收集和出售那些在其网站上接受所有Cookie的人的信息来创造收入。她有一句非常有趣的台词，她说，你可以说我们从读者那里获得的信息比他们从我们这里获得的信息更多。嗯嗯。嗯嗯。妮可由罗曼娜·杨饰演，我们去参观时采访了她。采访因他们需要她回片场而缩短了，但你可以去听听那个采访。
Yeah. Her and I found out we were both on the real O'Neils together. I know. You were on multiple things together, but you never really met. Never worked together. That's like me and Rob Lowe. We were on three projects together. Hold up. We never were in a scene together. Is there going to be a show? We're me and you and Roblo and Ramona. Well, I think we need to make it. On mom detective. Oh, my gosh. Case number one. Exactly.
对。她和我发现我们俩都曾一起出演过《年轻一代》。我知道。你们一起演过好几部剧，但你们从未真正见过面。从未合作过。这就好比我和罗伯·洛。我们一起参与过三个项目。等等。我们从来没有在同一个场景里出现过。会不会有一部剧？有我和你、罗伯·洛以及罗曼娜。好吧，我觉得我们需要拍一部。关于妈妈侦探的。哦，天哪。案件一。没错。
All right. Now we are going to meet Detrick, played by Melvin Gregg. I'm so bummed. We didn't get to interview Melvin. I know. We got to meet him, but we didn't get to interview him. We got to chat with him on set. Then they started rolling.
好了。现在我们要见德特里克，由梅尔文·格雷格饰演。我很沮丧。我们没能采访到梅尔文。我知道。我们见到了他，但我们没能采访他。我们在片场和他聊了聊。然后他们开始拍摄了。
We had to whisk away, and then he was in scenes. Yes. He explains that he sells ads for the paper. And we also learn that he likes to cheer people up specifically. Nicole. He's going to have a little crush on Nicole. Angela, we have seen Nicole's desk and Detrick's desk. Do you have a desk breakdown for us?
我们不得不匆忙离开，然后他就去拍戏了。是的。他解释说他为报社销售广告。我们还了解到他喜欢让人开心，尤其是妮可。他对妮可有点迷恋。安吉拉，我们看过妮可的桌子和德特里克的桌子。你能为我们做个办公桌大解构吗？
I do. Okay. So Nicole's desk, now you're going to see this a little bit more later in the episode. Right now we've only seen a quick glimpse of it. She has a framed picture of her dog, some type of like Stanley Cup, you know, like water bottle. Mm-hmm. Some little twinkly lights that it looks like she's sort of strung around her partition. The thing I'm most curious about is the bird cage that's got the little, you know, cloth covering it because the bird is clearly inside.
好的。那么妮可的桌子，接下来你会在本集后面看到更多。现在我们只匆匆瞥了一眼。她桌上有她狗的框镜照片，某种斯坦利杯，你知道的，就像水瓶一样。嗯嗯。一些看起来像是她缠绕在隔断周围的小闪烁灯光。我最好奇的是那个鸟笼，上面盖着一块小布，因为鸟显然在里面。
It's sleeping. It's sleeping. But yeah, she gets to bring her bird to work. And this made me think of a gal I worked with at 1,800 Dennis, who would bring her parakeet dash to work. In a cage, obviously, right? Not on her shoulder. I don't know why I said it in a cage. Actually, she had this little travel.
它在睡觉。它在睡觉。但是，是的，她可以带她的鸟去上班。这让我想起了我在1-800 Dennis工作时的一个同事，她会把她的长尾小鹦鹉达什带到上班的地方。当然是在笼子里，对吧？不是在她的肩膀上。我不知道我为什么要说在笼子里。实际上，她有这个小旅行箱。
I don't even know if I'd call it a cage container. It looked like a caboodle. Remember the makeup caboodles? Yeah. It was like plastic, but the top was kind of open and grated. Okay. And she could pop the lid open, and they let dash out. It was okay.
我都不知道该不该称之为笼子容器。它看起来像个化妆箱。还记得化妆箱吗？对。它就像是塑料的，但顶部有点开放并且有格栅。好吧。她可以弹开盖子，然后把达什放出来。没问题。
At 1-800 Dennis? At 1-800 Dennis? And he had a ball that he loved so much. It had a little bell inside it. And if you called 1-800 Dennis back in those days, you might have heard this in the background. Tiglingling, lily, like, tigling, lily, and that was Dash kicking his ball. I had two parakeets growing up.
在1-800 Dennis？在1-800 Dennis？它有一个它非常喜欢的球。里面有一个小铃铛。如果你在那些日子里给1-800 Dennis打电话，你可能会在背景里听到这个声音。叮铃铃，铃，就像，叮铃铃，铃，那就是达什在踢他的球。我从小养了两只长尾小鹦鹉。
Pretty was the name of the first parakeet, and Mango was the name of the second parakeet. And Mango used to fly around our house and would sit on my shoulder when I played piano. Yeah. Dash would hang out at Paula was the lady's name in her little desk cubicle, or he would kick his ball down. All of our desks were connected. So you might have Dash just traveling down. Wow. Yeah.
第一只长尾小鹦鹉叫漂亮，第二只长尾小鹦鹉叫芒果。芒果曾经在我们家飞来飞去，当我弹钢琴时会停在我的肩膀上。是的。达什会呆在宝拉（那是那个女人的名字）的小办公桌隔间里，或者他会把球踢下来。我们所有的桌子都是连在一起的。所以你可能会遇到达什到处闲逛。哇。是的。
I want more bird is all I'm saying. Okay, I'm now intrigued. We've seen it in the opening credits. Now I see the cage on her desk. When will we meet this bird? When will we meet this bird? Okay. Melvin's desk, I will say, is a little bit more of a typical desk.
我想要更多的鸟，我想说的就是这个。好吧，我现在很感兴趣。我们在片头字幕里看到了它。现在我在她的桌子上看到了鸟笼。我们什么时候能见到这只鸟？我们什么时候能见到这只鸟？好吧。我要说，梅尔文的桌子更像是一个典型的办公桌。
You know, papers, post-it notes, things like that. Not too personalized. Not super personalized, but oh my goodness. Melvin, we need to discuss your computer. screen. He had so many tabs open. Seriously, he has like 10 tabs open. So he's got some digital clutter, lady. There is one other desk that I think really rivals Asmeralda's for the amount of things, and we'll get to it. All right. Well, speaking of Esmeralda, she's kind of flirting with the camera. I loved this so much, lady. This is my favorite moment of the episode. Her
你知道的，文件、便签纸之类的。没有太多个性化。不是超级个性化，但是天哪。梅尔文，我们需要谈谈你的电脑屏幕。他开的标签页太多了。说真的，他大概开了10个标签页。所以他有一些数字杂物，女士。还有另一张桌子，我认为在物品数量上真的可以与埃斯梅拉达的相媲美，我们待会儿会讲到。好的。说到埃斯梅拉达，她有点在对着镜头调情。我太喜欢这个了，女士。这是本集我最喜欢的时刻。她的
acting is so brilliant. Cassie and I were talking about it when I got here because this is her favorite moment. Oh my gosh. We've got to hear it. Let's hear it. You're going to get tired chasing my busy little buddy around with that camera. Also, I'm a single mom, so there's lots going on in my life. Anyway, here are two accountants and the head accountant. Boring. Boring. Boring. and had boring. God, not again. I'm not agreeing to any of this. Don't you guys have enough after nine years?
演技太绝了。我来这儿时凯西和我还在谈论这个，因为这是她最喜欢的时刻。哦，天哪。我们得听听。让我们听听。你们会用那个相机跟着我这个忙碌的小伙伴到处跑而感到厌烦的。另外，我是个单亲妈妈，所以我的生活有很多事情要处理。不管怎样，这里有两个会计师和首席会计师。无聊。无聊。无聊和无聊。天哪，又来了。我才不同意这些。你们九年了还没拍够吗？
Nobody wants this. You know what? You can't use my voice, my likeness, my face, nothing. Oh my gosh. This was so fun. This is the reveal of Oscar. Yes, but the turn that she takes leading there where she's like flirty, flirty,
没有人想要这个。你知道吗？你不能用我的声音、我的肖像、我的脸，什么都不行。哦，天哪。这太有趣了。这是奥斯卡的揭晓。是的，但她在那之前的转变是她表现得很调情、很调情，
and then she's like, I'm a single mom, I got a lot going on. Yeah. And then she kicks it over, accounting. And then, yes, we discover Oscar. Yeah, he runs away. He's like, you heard it. You cannot use my like, there's nothing. I'm not doing this again. And he runs in the bathroom and he slams the door. And then the next thing we see is a title card with a message on it that says, yes, we can. There's no end date to the release Oscar signed in 2005. Yes. He's now a reluctant
然后她说，我是个单亲妈妈，我有很多事情要处理。是的。然后她把镜头转向会计。然后，是的，我们发现了奥斯卡。是的，他逃跑了。他说，你听到了。你不能用我的肖像，什么都没有。我再也不干了。然后他跑进卫生间，砰地关上门。然后我们看到的下一条是一个带有信息的标题卡，上面写着，是的，我们可以。奥斯卡在2005年签署的发布授权没有结束日期。是的。他现在是不情愿的
participant in this ongoing documentary. He's got to be so much. pissed off. Well, we're going to see this play out. Like we said, we got to see the first four episodes of the show. And without giving too much away, it's kind of a soft launch because he's going to be avoiding the cameras. He's going to get drawn in. But I really loved that. I love that. I love that we got to see this familiar face, but he's not in the main storylines at first. He's going to get slowly drawn in. Mm-hmm. I feel like we should mention the other members of this three-person boring accounting team because they're played by two more of the paper's writer performers, Bimasola Ikemelo and Alex Edelman.
参与者，参与到这个持续的纪录片中。他一定气死了。好吧，我们将看到事情的发展。就像我们说的，我们看到了该剧的前四集。在不剧透太多的情况下，这有点像是一次低调的首发，因为他将一直在躲避镜头。他会被吸引进来。但我真的很喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我喜欢我们看到了这个熟悉的面孔，但他一开始并不在主线剧情中。他会被慢慢吸引进来。嗯嗯。我觉得我们应该提一下这个三人无聊会计团队的其他成员，因为他们由另外两位该剧的编剧兼演员比玛索拉·伊凯梅洛和亚历克斯·埃德尔曼扮演。
And they play Adelola and Adam, the other two accountants. Mm-hmm. We're going to see Barry now. Barry's desk area is sort of that classic desk of someone who has worked at the same company for a long, long time. It has clutter, but it is clutter that. has earned its place. For example, his desk is situated by a big column that's part of the building, and he has covered that column with a whole bunch of little tiny newspaper clippings. Yes, probably articles he wrote over the years, I would think. We would hope. Well, Mayor is at her desk, and she's doing her business of pulling articles off the wire, and she just says, you know what, I need some air. And we're going to now go
他们饰演阿德洛拉和亚当，另外两名会计。嗯嗯。我们现在要见巴里了。巴里的办公桌区域有点像那种在同一家公司工作了很长时间的人的经典办公桌。它很杂乱，但这种杂乱是理所当然的。例如，他的办公桌位于建筑的一部分大柱子旁边，他用一大堆小小的剪报把那个柱子覆盖了。是的，可能是他多年来写的文章，我想。我们希望如此。好吧，梅尔坐在她的桌子前，她正在做从电线里拉出文章的业务，她只是说，你知道吗，我需要呼吸新鲜空气。我们现在要
outside, and we're going to see someone approaching the building. But I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we'll tell you who it is. Yes. We're going to meet a young man with purpose. Mm-hmm. All right. We are back, and we are going to meet Ned Sampson. He's this nice-looking young man. He's got a backpack on. He's played by Donald Gleason. Double crossover connection. He was in the miniseries The Patient with Steve Carell and the movie Fountain of Youth with John Krasinski. How about that? Well, we're going to learn, you know, he's super excited to be there. It's his first day working at The Truth Teller. And he shares growing up, he didn't idolize Superman.
出去，然后我们会看到有人走近大楼。但我认为我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们会告诉你他是谁。是的。我们要去见一个有目标的年轻人。嗯嗯。好的。我们回来了，我们要去见内德·萨姆森。他是一个长相清秀的年轻人。他背着一个背包。他由唐纳德·格里森饰演。双重跨界连接。他曾出演过与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作的迷你剧《局外人》以及与约翰·卡拉辛斯基合作的电影《青春之泉》。怎么样？好吧，我们要知道，你知道，他非常兴奋能来到这里。这是他在《真相播报》工作的第一天。他分享说，他在成长过程中崇拜的不是超人。
He worshipped Clark Kent, who was saving the world by working at a newspaper. Yes, he's very idealistic. Yes. And as he's talking, he kind of runs into mayor who kind of runs in. Yeah, he knocks her whole salad. She's carrying this big salad and he backs into her unknowingly with his enormous backpack, knocking her salad out of her hands, dumping it all over the ground. He never even sees her. All I could think about was Hugh Grant in this moment. Why? He hates backpacks. He does? Oh my gosh. Have you not heard? Heard him go off? No, I, okay, wait, this is so funny because I know what you're talking about.
他崇拜的是克拉克·肯特，他通过在报社工作来拯救世界。是的，他非常理想主义。是的。当他说话时，他有点撞上了梅尔，梅尔跑了进来。是的，他撞掉了她整盘沙拉。她端着这盘大沙拉，而他背着他巨大的背包，在不知情的情况下撞向她，把她手里的沙拉打翻在地，散落一地。他甚至连看都没看她一眼。我当时脑子里只想到了休·格兰特。为什么？他讨厌背包。他讨厌？哦，天哪。你没听说过吗？听过他大发雷霆？没有，我，好吧，等等，这太搞笑了，因为我知道你在说什么。
Yes, both him and also Kate Blanchette, have you seen these compilations of them going on and on about the things that they hate? She hates leaf blowers. She does. Like so much she hates them. I think you need to hear his hatred of backpacks, though. Here's a clip of him talking about it on late night with Seth Myers. You are a man who you said, I believe, you are a walking pet peeve in that you have a lot of pet peeves about human behavior.
是的，包括他和凯特·布兰切特，你见过他们滔滔不绝地谈论他们讨厌的事情的合集吗？她讨厌吹叶机。她确实讨厌。她讨厌的程度太深了。不过我想你需要听听他对背包的讨厌。这里有一段他在《塞斯·迈尔斯深夜秀》上谈论这件事的剪辑。你是一个这样的人，我相信，你是行走的讨厌点，你在人类行为方面有很多看不惯的地方。
Yeah, I'm an angry little man. Yeah. Can I read off some of your pet peeves and have you tee off? You don't like people walking slowly. I'm bearable. Backpacks. You don't care for backpacks. What's all that? Why has everyone got a backpack? Take it off. Take it off.
是的，我是一个容易生气的矮个子男人。对。我可以读出你的一些怪癖，然后让你发泄一下吗？你讨厌别人走路很慢。这我还能忍受。双肩包。你不在乎双肩包。那都是些什么？为什么每个人都有双肩包？脱下来。脱下来。
But what if they have their stuff in it? I don't care. Carry it here. Okay. Oh, it's that. It's a bag's not an issue. It's that it's on your back. Well, I use the subway, the tube in London quite a lot because you can't get around any other way.
但如果他们的东西放在里面呢？我不管。拿到这里来。好吧。哦，原来是这样。包本身不是问题。问题是它背在你的背上。好吧，我在伦敦经常坐地铁，因为没有别的办法出行。
And there's always someone's huge backpack in my face with their stupid water bottle. So you also don't care for water bottles. Why does everyone need a water bottle? So basically, I think Hugh Grant would really hate Ned's backpack. Oh, for sure. It took out a whole salad. And he doesn't even notice.
而且总有人巨大的双肩包贴在我的脸上，还带着他们愚蠢的水瓶。所以你也不在乎水瓶。为什么每个人都需要一个水瓶？所以基本上，我觉得休·格兰特一定会讨厌内德的双肩包。哦，肯定的。它带走了一整份沙拉。而且他甚至都没注意到。
I know. All right. Well, he's going to go upstairs to these offices, and he walks in, and no one is expecting him. He's just a guy with a backpack who's walked in. He goes into the copy room. He's kind of wandering around. He's filming and taking pictures. He's so excited.
我知道。好吧，他要上楼去这些办公室，然后他走了进去，没有人料到他的到来。他只是一个背着双肩包走进来的人。他走进了复印室。他到处闲逛。他在拍视频和照片。他太兴奋了。
He looks like a tourist. He looks out of place for sure. So Nicole clocks him, and she goes over, and she locks him inside of this copy room, which is a glass room. Yeah. And now employees start wandering over, and then Ned is going to discover that he's been locked in the room. And this whole exchange, it made me laugh very hard. I think we need to hear it. We do not have door money.
他看起来像个游客。他看起来确实格格不入。所以妮可注意到了他，她走了过去，把他反锁在这个复印室里，这是一个玻璃房间。是的。现在员工们开始溜达过来，然后内德将发现自己被锁在房间里。而这段互动，让我笑得前仰后合。我觉得我们得听听看。我们没有门费。
This is just a misunderstanding, okay? I just, I start work at the paper. Which paper, news or toilet? News. Why would I say the paper about toilet paper? We don't know you, sir. How should we know why you say the things you say? I've got a meeting at 2 o'clock, all right?
这只是一场误会，好吗？我只是，我开始在报社工作。哪家报社，新闻还是厕纸？新闻。我为什么会说关于厕纸的报社？我们不认识你，先生。我们怎么知道你为什么会说那些话？我两点钟有个会，好吗？
I'm just early. That's all this is. Okay. Who's a meeting with? Just briefly, I'm forgetting the name. No, no, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. It's something unique. Is there a, is there a fantine that works here?
我只是来早了。事情就是这样。好吧。和谁开会？简单来说，我忘了名字。不，不，不，等等，等等，等等，等等。那是个很独特的。有没有，这里有没有一个芳汀？
You'll find her in Les Més. All right. I really love Detrick in that scene. Yes. We don't know why you say the things you say, sir. Yeah. Well, Ned finally remembers Esmeralda's name, at the same time that Mayer finally returns and says,
你会在《悲惨世界》里找到她。好吧。我真的很喜欢那一幕里的德特里克。是的。我们不知道你为什么会说那些话，先生。是的。嗯，内德终于记住了埃斯梅拉达的名字，与此同时迈尔终于回来了并说道：
Oh, my gosh, I saw this guy downstairs. He was talking to the camera crew. He's legit. Yes. They let him out. I want to point out at 14 minutes and 49 seconds, we see behind Ned in the copy room on the side of a filing cabinet, the same yellow froggy 101 radio sticker that was on the set of the office. Oh, my gosh.
哦，天哪，我在楼下看到这个家伙了。他在和摄像团队说话。他是合法的。是的。他们放他出来了。我想指出的是，在14分49秒时，我们看到复印室里内德身后的文件柜侧面，贴着那个黄色的青蛙101电台贴纸，就是《办公室》片场出现过的那个。哦，天哪。
Yes. Little Easter egg. Well, I spotted an Easter egg on Oscars' desk that we're going to talk about later. Yes, and I have a clip. Oh, well, it's making me wonder if there are more of these. Like, if I watch it again, will I see more of them in the background? I think so. I think they're hidden all over.
是的。一个小彩蛋。嗯，我在奥斯卡的桌子上发现了一个彩蛋，我们稍后会讨论。是的，我有一个剪辑。哦，这让我怀疑是不是还有更多这样的彩蛋？比如，如果我再看一遍，我会在背景里看到更多吗？我想是的。我觉得它们到处都藏着。
You think there's a Simpsons thing somewhere? I would think so. Right? I looked for it. If I missed it, let me know. Or a ducky? I don't know. I did see a stuffed animal in a filing cabinet.
你觉得哪里有什么辛普森的元素吗？我想是的。对吧？我找过了。如果我漏掉了，请告诉我。或者一只小黄鸭？我不知道。我确实在文件柜里看到了一个毛绒玩具。
I couldn't really make out what it was. Okay, for future viewings. Mm-hmm. So when they let Ned out of the conference room, everyone's going to kind of come up and introduce him. But my favorite is when Travis, the softy toilet paper guy, shakes his hand and then turns it into like a pat down, just to make sure. I love the character of Travis. We have watched a few upcoming episodes. There are a few scenes that he's in that crack me up. Eric, you are hilarious. Yes, he's played by Eric Rayhill, and he is our final writer performer.
我真的没认出来那是什么。好吧，留着以后看的时候找。嗯。所以当他们把内德从会议室放出来时，每个人都走过来自我介绍。但我最喜欢的是特拉维斯，那个软心厕纸男，握了他的手，然后顺势变成了一次搜身，就是为了确认一下。我喜欢特拉维斯这个角色。我们看过一些即将播出的剧集。他参演的一些场景让我笑得前仰后合。埃里克，你太搞笑了。是的，他由埃里克·雷希尔饰演，他是我们最后一位编剧兼演员。
Oh, he is so funny. Yes. So Ned explains he's a new employee. Mayor is immediately worried that she's fired because she knows we don't have room for new employees. They get to chatting, and he's like, I'm a little shaken up. I could use a bite to eat before my meeting. I owe you a salad. You want to get something to eat.
哦，他太搞笑了。是的。所以内德解释说他是新员工。迈尔立刻担心自己被解雇了，因为她知道我们没有新员工的位置。他们聊了起来，他说，我有点受到惊吓。在开会前我得吃点东西。我欠你一份沙拉。你想吃点东西吗。
She's like, sure. They now go down to a little cafe. It looks like it's maybe somewhere in the building. right? Like on the mezzanine level of the building? Yes. It's called Eat Huss. Mm-hmm. Get it? Eat House. Eat House. Yeah. And this is where the two of them start to get to know each other. It's such a lovely scene. I love Chelsea in this scene. Yeah. I love her. I have to imagine that when Greg was watching her in this scene, he was dazzled because she's incredible. She's so great, Ned. I did have questions. This is when I wish we had the script, because Ned does the thing where he's picking out all of the tomatoes out of his salad? Yes, he's like talking about his
她说，好啊。他们现在来到一个小咖啡馆。看起来好像在大楼里的某个地方？对吧？就像大楼的夹层？是的。它叫Eat Huss。嗯。明白了吗？Eat House。Eat House。是的。这就是两人开始互相了解的地方。这是一个非常可爱的场景。我喜欢这个场景中的切尔西。是的。我喜欢她。我忍不住想象格雷格在这个场景中看她表演时一定眼花缭乱，因为她太不可思议了。她太棒了，内德。我确实有问题。这时候我希望我们有剧本，因为内德在做一件事，他把沙拉里的所有西红柿都挑出来？是的，他在谈论他的
backstory where he came from, but all the while he's picking at his salad. Like separating things out of it. And she becomes very sort of fixated on that. She's like, what are you doing? And I was like, that had to have been in the script. Like he didn't just do that, right? I don't think so because he has a very funny line where he says, oh, this is the pile of things I don't want to eat from the salad. This is the pile of eat alone's, and then this is the salad. That's right. That's right. I just loved that writing.
背景故事，他从哪里来，但与此同时他在挑拣他的沙拉。就像把里面的东西分类一样。她开始对此非常专注。她说，你在干什么？我想，这一定在剧本里吧？他不可能只是临时发挥，对吧？我不这么觉得，因为他有一句非常搞笑的台词，他说，哦，这是我不想从沙拉里吃的东西堆。这是单独吃的堆，然后这是沙拉。没。错。没错。我太喜欢这段台词了。
But what I do wonder is, is there someone in the writer's room who does that to their salad? I'm sure. You know all these things make their way in. That's right. So we find out that Ned started by working at his father's cardboard company, then through a connection that his dad had at Enervate, he ends up working at Softies in Chicago. And now, per his request, he's been moved to Toledo. to work at the newspaper. We also learned that he's a very good salesman.
但我好奇的是，编剧室里是不是真有人吃沙拉也这样？肯定的。你知道所有这些细节都会进入剧本。没错。所以我们发现内德最初是在他父亲的纸板公司工作，然后通过他爸爸在恩内尔维特公司的人脉，他最终去了芝加哥的“软心纸巾”工作。现在，应他的要求，他被调到了托莱多去报社工作。我们还了解到他是个非常优秀的销售人员。
Yes. And we learn a little bit about his vision for what he wants to do here. We're now going to cut back to the offices where some people are talking. There's a hilarious conversation between Oscar and Travis, where Travis is sort of telling him how to behave if you ever hit a deer with your car, what to do with your car, to avoid hitting the deer. This scene was so funny. And this is a scene that I think might have gotten cut.
是的。我们还了解了他对在这里想做的事情的一些设想。现在我们将切回办公室，那里有些人正在谈话。奥斯卡和特拉维斯之间有一段非常搞笑的对话，特拉维斯在告诉他，如果你开车撞了一头鹿应该怎么表现，该怎么处理你的车，以避免撞到鹿。这个场景太搞笑了。而且我觉得这可能是一个被剪掉的场景。
if you only had 21 minutes. Yes. Because there's no purpose for this other than to just be very, very funny, to just watch two funny people in a funny scene. It does have a moment, though, that furthers the storyline that Oscar doesn't want to be in it. Because when Oscar sees the camera, he kind of scoches behind his computer monitor. Yes, that's true. So that does serve that purpose. But I couldn't help but think that Travis and Dwight would get along really well.
如果你只有21分钟的话。是的。因为除了非常好笑、看着两个搞笑的人在一个搞笑的场景里之外，它没有任何其他目的。不过，它确实有一个推动剧情发展的时刻，那就是奥斯卡不想出镜。因为当奥斯卡看到摄像机时，他有点躲到了电脑显示器后面。是的，确实如此。所以它确实达到了这个目的。但我忍不住觉得特拉维斯和德怀特一定会非常合得来。
Definitely based on this speech. Mm-hmm. And the pat down. And the pat down, you're right. I do want to give a quick shout out to Scott McGinnis, who is the prop master for the paper. We chatted with him when we visited the set and we exchanged emails. He shared with us that he knew Phil Shea well, and he did a lot of the same things for the paper, like reaching out to local businesses for menus, magnets, etc.
绝对是根据这段对话来看。嗯。还有搜身。还有搜身，你说得对。我要向斯科特·麦吉尼斯表达由衷的谢意，他是报社的道具师。我们访问片场时和他聊过，还交换了电子邮件。他跟我们分享说，他很了解菲尔·谢伊，他为报社做了很多同样的事情，比如联系当地商家获取菜单、磁贴等。
That Phil did for the office with the local Scranton businesses. And I asked Scott what it was like to work on the paper, and he said, is it possible to work with Greg Daniels without a story? He's wonderful. And I did ask him if we ever get to see that bird, and he said yes. Oh, got some inside scoop. Yeah. Well, now we're going to have a talking head by the character Adelola, and she's telling us about her deskmate, Adam. He has four kids. His wife makes him the same lunch every day. He basically eats. He basically eats whatever the kids don't want to eat. And I guess you could say I'm not sure she thinks very highly
就像菲尔为办公室对接当地斯克兰顿商家那样。我问斯科特在报社工作是什么感觉，他说，怎么可能在没有故事的情况下跟格雷格·丹尼尔斯合作呢？他太棒了。我确实问过他我们是否能看到那只鸟，他说能。哦，拿到了一些内部消息。嗯。现在我们将看到角色阿德洛拉的一个独白镜头，她跟我们讲述了她的同桌亚当。他有四个孩子。他妻子每天给他做同样的午餐。他基本上吃的是。他基本上吃孩子们不想吃的东西。我想你可以说，我不确定她对他的评价有多高。
of him. While she's saying all of this, it's so hilarious to me because they cut to Adam. He is drinking out of a dinosaur sippy cup. He's like literally eating a kid's lunch. It's really funny. We see a little bit of both of their desks in this montage, and I thought I'd share with you. First of all, Adelola's desk, she's got a lot on her desk. She's got a lot on her desk. She's got a lot of papers, a lot of things. It's a little messy. But I think she's where people go to get little treats because on the front of her desk she has glass canisters of candy. Oh! Kind of reminded me of Pam's desk a little bit. Okay. Okay. Adam's desk is the one I was talking about, like Esmeralda's, holy moly, how many more things could you fit on this desk? It is wall-to-wall
在她说着这一切的时候，我觉得太搞笑了，因为镜头切到了亚当。他正用一个恐龙吸管杯喝水。他简直就像在吃小孩子的午餐。这真的太搞笑了。在这个蒙太奇中，我们看到了他们两个办公桌的一些特写，我想和你们分享一下。首先是阿德洛拉的桌子，她桌上有好多东西。她桌上有好多东西。她有很多文件，很多杂物。有点乱。但我认为人们如果想吃小零食都会去找她，因为她的办公桌前面摆着装糖果的玻璃罐。哦！这有点让我想起潘的桌子。好吧。好吧。亚当的桌子就是我刚才说的那个，就像埃斯梅拉达的桌子一样，天哪，这桌上怎么还能塞下这么多东西。简直是满满当当。
things. And when we visited the set, we actually talked to Alex while he was at his desk and he described it a little bit for us. I have various books that are, you can only see the spines of. This is a book by Ken Koppas, who directed the second episode. And it's facing in so he can't see the spine, but it says, but what I really want to do is direct, which is what Ken, um, Ken gave me the book. This is a book about one of my mentors in my job before comedy. A guy named Larry Lukino used to run the Red Sox. The book's called Masters of the Game. And so, um, and yeah, and because my character is a dad, he's got a bunch of, like, he can't play at home. So I've got a bunch of toys, like these Velcro ball catchers, like Rubik's cubes, like this, um, fart gun. Yeah, it does different
当我们访问片场时，我们实际上采访了亚历克斯，当时他正坐在办公桌前，他为我们稍微描述了一下。我有各种各样的书，你只能看到书脊。这是一本由肯·科普斯写的书，他执导了第二集。它面朝里面，所以他看不到书脊，但上面写着，“但我真正想做的是导演”，这是肯，嗯，肯送给我的书。这是一本关于我在喜剧之前的工作中的一位导师的书。一个叫拉里·卢基诺的家伙，以前经营红袜队。这本书叫《游戏大师》。所以，嗯，是的，因为我的角色是一个爸爸，他有很多，比如，他不能在家里玩。所以我有很多玩具，比如这些魔术贴球拍，比如魔方，就像这个，嗯，放屁枪。是的，它能发出不同的屁声。
farts. I have a question. Yeah. I have a question about this container of a toothpick cleaners, floss picks. Is that, is that props or is that you? Oh, that's props. You only, The stuff that's made, but I love all of the props. This is a mini bopit. I'm really good at mini bopit, but once, like, in an early episode at, like, a 6 a.m. call time, I was, like, doing the bopet, like, in a bit of a trance state. And I looked up, and everyone was, like, watching me. It was the wrong kind of attention.
我有个问题。嗯。我关于这个牙签清洁器、牙线棒的容器有个问题。这是，这是道具还是你自己的？哦，这是道具。只有，那些制造出来的东西，但我喜欢所有的道具。这是一个迷你的抓抓乐。我非常擅长玩迷你抓抓乐，但有一次，在早期的一集中，比如早上6点的通告时间，我，像是在有点出神的状态下，在玩抓抓乐。我抬起头，每个人都在，像是在看着我。那是错误类型的关注。
I have a question about this Boston Snow Globe. Is your character, does your character have a Boston backstory? My character, like me, does have a Boston backstory? Boston backstory. I'm from, I'm a proud Brookline, Massachusetts. Not a Newtonian, like Novak and Krasinski. But it's a bit of a tribute to
我关于这个波士顿雪景球有一个问题。你的角色，你的角色有波士顿的背景故事吗？我的角色和我一样，确实有波士顿的背景故事吗？波士顿背景故事。我来自，我是个骄傲的马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩人。不是像诺瓦克和克拉辛斯基那种牛顿人。但这算是一个致敬。
all of the Bostonians who have come through the show. And, yeah, my character is from Boston originally, although it's never come up. I see that you also have the magic eight ball on your desk, which was in Michael Scott's office,
致敬所有经历过这部剧的波士顿人。而且，是的，我的角色原本来自波士顿，虽然剧情里从来没提过。我看到你的桌上还有一个魔术8球，它曾经出现在迈克尔·斯科特的办公室里，
and a magic eight ball seems to find its way onto a desk in every iteration of the office. So, you know, that wasn't my choice, but when I noticed it, I kept hoping that no one would call me on it because I really wanted to keep it because I was such a big fan of the original show. And so I thought, oh, man, Oscar has his little nod to Michael Scott. I love that I get to have a little tiny nod to Michael Scott, too, but there are so many. Yes. I have a bevy of chapsticks. I have lots of chapsticks. And this is a ball signed by a bunch of the crew, which is a really nice thing to have. And, yeah, there are lots of little nods to the crew around the office. A lot of the employees of the month or the, yeah, a lot of the plaques. And, like, is a really fun set. Isn't that great? Yeah. He also went on to show us all the pictures that are, quote, unquote, all of his mini kids. And they're just all of his friends, kids.
而且在《办公室》的每一个版本中，魔术8球似乎总能找到自己的位置出现在某张桌子上。所以，你知道，这不是我的选择，但当我注意到它时，我一直希望没有人会点破它，因为我真的很想把它留下，因为我是原版剧集的超级粉丝。所以我想，哦，天哪，奥斯卡有他对迈克尔·斯科特的小致敬。我喜欢我也有机会对迈克尔·斯科特做一点小小的致敬，但这里有太多了。是的。我有一堆润唇膏。我有好多润唇膏。这是由许多剧组人员签名的一个球，拥有它真的很棒。而且，是的，办公室周围有很多向剧组人员致敬的小细节。很多月度员工或者，是的，很多牌匾。而且，这是一个非常有趣的片场。是不是很棒？是的。他接着向我们展示了所有被称为“他的迷你孩子们”的照片。而那其实全都是他朋友的孩子们。
like people that he holds dear to his heart. But his desk had so many toys. It had a marble racer, had all these things. But I loved hearing how there was a little bit of things from his life, plus things that are props, plus nods to the office. And I also just love how they continue the tradition like we had on the office of having crew featured in all these little places on plaques and things. I love that too.
就像他内心深处珍视的人。但他的桌子上有好多的玩具。有弹珠赛车，有各种各样的东西。但我很喜欢听到他是如何将自己生活中的一些东西、道具以及对《办公室》的致敬结合在一起的。我也很喜欢他们如何延续我们在《办公室》中的传统，让剧组人员出现在所有这些小地方的牌匾和事物中。我也很喜欢这一点。
Well, now we're going back to lunch. And now it's mayor's turn to open up. And they're going to kind of agree together that this paper sucks, but maybe they can make it better. Maybe it can be a real paper. Yeah. But in order to do that, Ned is going to have to meet Esmeralda. And he's going to have to tell her that he is taking her job. Yeah, he's editor-in-chief now.
好吧，现在我们要回到午餐。现在轮到迈尔敞开心扉了。他们将一致认为这家报社简直烂透了，但也许他们能让它变得更好。也许它可以成为一家真正的报社。是的。但为了做到这一点，内德将不得不见埃斯梅拉达。而且他必须告诉她，他要取代她的工作。是的，他现在是总编辑了。
She can still run the online part. But he's going to basically replace her. Yeah, he's in charge of the print paper now. And he makes this apology to her. He's like, I'm sorry, I hope me coming in here and changing things up won't be too disruptive. And she says, oh, don't be so self-deficating. Yes. She just clearly has him in her bullseye.
她仍然可以运营在线部分。但他基本上要取代她。是的，他现在负责印刷报纸。他向她道歉。他说，我很抱歉，希望我进来改变这一切不会带来太多干扰。她说，哦，别这么自贬身价了。是的。她显然已经把他当作自己的靶子了。
And now she is going to just start taking jabs at him in all the tiniest and big ways. Yeah, there's going to be some future storylines that play out that are just her really, like, undermining him. but she pretends like... She's in his corner. Oh, it's just lost in translation, maybe. Like, I... Oh, there's one coming up, actually. Yes.
现在她要开始以各种最小和最大的方式对他冷嘲热讽了。是的，未来的剧情会有一些发展，全都是她真正在架空他。但她假装……她站在他这边。哦，也许只是翻译上有偏差吧？比如，我……哦，实际上马上就有一个要发生了。是的。
Well, I also want to say, I just love that she's holding her cell phone in the scene. It's just so true to character. This is totally a person who walks around with their cell phone in their hand all the time, and she does, and I love it.
好吧，我还要说的是，我太喜欢她在这个场景中拿着手机的样子了。这太符合她的人设了。这绝对是一个整天拿着手机到处走的人，她就是这样，我太爱了。
We are now going to have our first conference room scene. Yes. It's just between Ned and Ken, who is the guy we met at the beginning, who works for Enervate and Esmeralda. And basically, Ned is saying, listen, I'm going to need a few things to make the kind of newspaper I want to make.
现在我们将迎来我们的第一个会议室场景。是的。这只发生在内德和肯之间，肯就是我们在开始时遇到的那个为恩内尔维特公司工作的人，还有埃斯梅拉达。基本上，内德是在说，听着，我要做我想做的这种报纸，需要一些东西。
I'm going to need a full staff, dedicated reporters on multiple beats. And Ken is like, whoopsies, I'm going to call 911 because our budget is having a coronary. And he says, you know what else? I am going to cancel the wire service. We are only going to print original articles from this point on. Esmeralda looks right at the camera like, who the F is this? A-hole. I know. Now, meanwhile, during this conference room scene, we see everyone out in the bullpen getting an email on their computers. It's from Esmeralda.
我需要一个完整的员工团队，在多个跑线上有专门的记者。而肯则说，哎呀，我要拨打911了，因为我们的预算正在心肌梗死。他说，你知道还有什么吗？我要取消通讯社服务。从今以后我们只印刷原创文章。埃斯梅拉达直勾勾地看着摄像机，仿佛在说：这混蛋到底是谁？我知道。与此同时，在这个会议室场景中，我们看到外面的大办公区里的每个人都在电脑上收到了一封电子邮件。是埃斯梅拉达发来的。
Well, she's been clicking away. As soon as he started telling her the wire was going away and how he was going to change things, she is busy on her phone during this meeting. And what she's been doing is writing a letter to the staff titled Welcome Ned Samson. and we're going to see people reading it, and one by one, people kind of start, like, coming over and looking in the room. Yeah, one guy comes over to the conference room and is like, hey, I'm here for you, guy. You know, same thing happened to me, here for it to show you my support. And he leaves, and everyone's kind of like, what was that about? And Ken goes, I didn't even think that guy worked here anymore.
嗯，她一直在敲击键盘。就在他开始告诉她通讯社服务要取消以及他将如何改变现状时，她在这次会议期间一直在忙着发手机。而她一直在做的是写一封写给全体员工的信，标题是《欢迎内德·萨姆森》。然后我们将看到人们在阅读它，一个人接一个人，大家开始，呃，走过来往房间里看。是的，有一个人走到会议室说，嘿，我支持你，兄弟。你知道，我也有过同样的遭遇，我来这里是为了向你表达我的支持。然后他离开了，大家都有点像，刚刚那是怎么回事？肯说，我甚至不知道那个家伙还在不在这里上班。
Everyone else starts to walk up to the conference room, and there are these glass windows, and they're looking through it pretty harshly. at Ned, they are not happy. Ken is oblivious, but you can tell Esmeralda is delighted. Well, Ned is going to excuse himself, and Mayor is going to show him something on her phone. It is the email, and here's what it is. Asmeralda has sent an email to everyone explaining that Ned has not been me-toed. That's not why he came here, why he had to get a new job. It was not because he was me-toed. Yes. So he has this conversation with Esmeralda, where he's like, why would you send an email telling people that I was not something, that I was not me-toed? Her explanation is so funny. She's being so manipulative. It's amazing. I think we should hear it.
其他人开始走向会议室，那里有玻璃窗，他们非常严厉地透过玻璃看着内德，他们很不高兴。肯毫无察觉，但你能看出埃斯梅拉达很高兴。好吧，内德要失陪一下，迈尔要给他看手机上的东西。那封电子邮件，内容是这样的。埃斯梅拉达给每个人发了一封邮件，解释说内德没有被“MeToo”过。这不是他来这里的原因，不是他为什么得换一份新工作。不是因为他被“MeToo”了。是的。所以他和埃斯梅拉达有了这样一段对话，他质问她：你为什么要发邮件告诉大家我没有被怎么样，我没有被“MeToo”？她的解释太搞笑了。她太有操控欲了。这太神了。我觉得我们应该听听看。
Hey, can we talk? Of course. No. No. No. Her. Did you send an email to everyone here saying that I was not me-tube. Yes, because I didn't want you to start off on the wrong foot. But I wasn't. Yes, in fact, that's why I said he was not me tooed. I don't think. I was not, I've never been me tooed. I've also never embezzled or slapped a waitress. Oh, well, should I tell them?
嘿，我们能谈谈吗？当然。不。不。不。她。你是不是给这里的每个人发了一封邮件，说我没有被“MeToo”？是的，因为我不想让你出师不利。但我本来就没有。是的，事实上，这就是为什么我说他没有被“MeToo”。我不认为。我没有，我从来没有被“MeToo”过。我也从来没有挪用公款或者扇过女服务员耳光。哦，好吧，我是不是该告诉他们？
Maybe. No, that's what I'm saying. You don't have to knot a thing that isn't. You are preaching to the choir. These are simple people. To them, a man leaves his job, moves to a new town. They think, I wonder what was his evil crime. Did he do it to a person?
也许吧。不，这就是我要说的。你不需要否认一件根本不存在的事。你这简直是对牛弹琴。这些都是单纯的人。对他们来说，一个男人离开工作，搬到一个新镇子。他们会想，不知道他犯了什么滔天大罪。他对人下手了吗？
An animal? An animal? I hope he doesn't do it to me. That's why I wrote a mass email to everyone. So instead, they would think, wait a minute, hold on. Maybe I should wait and see. What if my gut instinct against him is... Okay.
对动物？对动物？我希望他不要对我下手。这就是为什么我给所有人写了一封群发邮件。这样一来，他们就会想，等一下，等一下。也许我应该等等看。万一我对他的直觉是……好吧。
It's not completely, completely, completely right. Okay, this is bad, as Marilda. You know what? I'm going to tell everyone that everything that I wrote in that email was completely incorrect, okay? Thank you. Okay, you're welcome. You're welcome.
并不是完完全全、百分之百正确。好吧，这太糟糕了，埃斯梅拉达。你知道吗？我要告诉大家，我那封邮件里写的一切完全不正确，好吧？谢谢。好吧，不客气。不客气。
No, wait, wait, wait. I think that's worse. Why? Why? I think it's better if it comes from me. I agree. Great idea. Everybody's going to appreciate your remarks.
不，等等，等等，等等。我觉得那样更糟。为什么？为什么？我觉得由我来说会更好。我同意。好主意。大家会感谢你的发言的。
Cool. No, not now. Not now. Everyone. Everyone. Everyone! The way, the scene is brilliant. She is just a master class in acting,
酷。不，不是现在。不是现在。所有人。所有人。所有人！这种，这个场景简直绝了。她在演技上堪称大师班，
and then her way she yells at everyone to listen up. It's so incredible. So good. Poor Ned is just deer in headlights. Yes. Well, he is, in fact, going to take the floor. He's going to stand up on. one of the desks in the middle of the bullpen, you know, this is the photo we've all been seeing.
然后她大喊让大家静下来听她说的那个方式。太不可思议了。太棒了。可怜的内德就像一只在车灯前吓呆的鹿。是的。好吧，他事实上要走上台了。他要站到大办公区中间的一张桌子上，你知道，这就是我们都见过的那张照片。
They released a photo of this moment when they were promoting the show. So this scene gives us this really great wide shot of the offices. You can see Ned standing on top of the desk. You can see the softy toilet paper side. You can see the truth teller side. And I have to give a shout out to the production designer, Susie Mancini, who also worked with Greg on Space Force and Adrian Garcia. who was the set decorator, Greg and Michael shared with us that in the same way that Greg visited like a small paper company when he was developing the office, he and Michael visited
他们在宣传这部剧时发布了一张这个时刻的照片。所以这个场景给了我们一个办公室非常棒的全景镜头。你可以看到内德站在桌子顶上。你可以看到软心厕纸那一侧。你可以看到真相传达者那一侧。我必须要向制作设计师苏西·曼奇尼致敬，她曾和格雷格在《太空部队》中合作过，还有作为布景师的阿德里安·加西亚。格雷格和迈尔斯告诉我们，就像格雷格在开发《办公室》时参观了一家小型纸业公司一样，他和迈尔斯在开发报社时参观了俄亥俄州的几家小型报社。
several small newspaper offices in Ohio when they were developing the paper. And he said that something they noticed was that these old offices, they have a lot of style because this was the big like Google type company of their era. And the set of the paper is modeled after some of the things that they observed touring these historic newspaper offices. They wanted to create a place that felt like it had history. And I think you can see that. You can see that with the big columns in the room. Those windows, to me, really sell it. The windows are sort of this half moon. They sort of arch up high and come around. Yes. And there's these other big windows that are like trimmed in hard wood. Yes. There's also this divider that has like dark wood trim around it and all this iron work.
他说他们注意到的一点是，这些老旧的办公室很有风格，因为这是他们那个时代的“谷歌”式大公司。报社的布景是以他们参观这些历史悠久的报社时观察到的一些事物为原型设计的。他们想创造一个感觉有历史感的地方。我想你能看出来。从房间里的大柱子就能看出来。在我看来，那些窗户真的很有质感。那些窗户有点像半月形。它们呈拱形向上弯曲并合拢。是的。还有其他的大窗户，上面有硬木镶边。是的。还有一个隔板，周围有深色木质边框和所有这些铁艺。
looks like it's from the 1920s, but they did an amazing job with this set. And this is, I think, the first time you get to really see the scope of it. Well, we have a few background catches during this great big wide shot. Lady, you texted me and said, Ange, what is that at 24 minutes and four seconds? Is it what I think it is? Yes, it's something on Oscar's desk. Alex mentioned it. Yes, he referred to it. Yes. Here's what it is, you guys. Check it out. Oscar has on his desk that scarecrow doll made out of like burlap and twine that Michael Scott gave him in the Goodbye Michael episode.
看起来像是20世纪20年代的风格，但他们在布景上做得太棒了。我想这是你第一次真正看到它的规模。好吧，在这个宏大的全景镜头中，我们捕捉到了一些背景彩蛋。女士，你发短信给我说，安琪，24分04秒那个是什么？是我想的那样吗？是的，那是奥斯卡桌上的东西。亚历克斯提到了它。是的，他提到了。是的。大家看，这就是那个东西。看一看。奥斯卡的桌上放着那个用麻布和麻绳制作的稻草人大玩偶，就是迈尔斯·斯科特在“再见迈尔斯”那一集里送给他的那个。
Do you remember the moment? Here, let's hear it. Oscar, Oscar, Oscar. Oscar, you are very smart and you have a gigantic education. And I think of you as my scarecrow. because you gave me a brain. So that's why I made you this. Thank you, Michael.
你还记得那个时刻吗？来吧，我们听听看。奥斯卡，奥斯卡，奥斯卡。奥斯卡，你非常聪明，你有着巨大的学历。我把你当成我的稻草人。因为你给了我一个大脑。这就是为什么我为你做了这个。谢谢你，迈尔斯。
It's beautiful. It looks like it was made by a two-year-old monkey on a farm. And he just, he just accepted that I put it. that I put all this work into it? Oh, man. He is the lowest opinion of me, of anybody. Oh. No one fake laughs better than Steve Carell, by the way.
这太美了。它看起来像农场里的两岁猴子做的。而他居然，居然接受了我放上去的？我投入了这么多心血？哦，天哪。他对我的评价是所有人里面最低的。哦。顺便说一句，没有人能比史蒂夫·卡瑞尔假笑得更好了。
Well, this is true. I mean, I am, like, laughing because it's like that laugh sounds so real, but that's all performance. Yes. But, yeah, that's what Oscar has on his desk. Oscar brought that all the way from Scranton, and then he put it on his desk. Maybe he liked Michael. after all. Aw.
嗯，这倒也是。我是说，我，我在笑，是因为那个笑声听起来太真实了，但那全是表演。是的。但是，是的，这就是奥斯卡放在桌子上的东西。奥斯卡把那个一路从斯克兰顿带过来，然后放到了他的桌上。也许他其实挺喜欢迈尔斯的。噢。
Well, lady, I know you have another catch because I caught it, too. Mm-hmm. This is just what we're going to call fantastic shoe catch. And Adelola has on some sparkly, bedazzled, shimmering boots. They're like a hot pink. Yeah. They're amazing. Yeah, her legs are up on her desk.
好吧，女士，我知道你还有另一个发现，因为我也抓到了。嗯。这就是我们要说的神奇鞋子大发现。阿德洛拉穿着一双闪闪发光、镶满水钻、波光粼粼的靴子。它们是亮粉色的。是的。太棒了。是的，她的腿翘在办公桌上。
I spotted them as well. Well, now Ned is going to continue his pitch for what he wants to do at the paper. And here's what he says. He says, quote, if you have ever wanted to be the first person to know what's going on in the place where you live, or if you want to make sure the people who are running your city are telling the truth and doing the things that they said they would do, or if you just root for the underdog and you want to give it to the loud mouths, you are more than welcome all of you to volunteer your time at this newspaper. Because he says, I can't hire you. Mm-hmm. And he spots Marv across the room. And he says, Marv, is that okay? Can people spend a little bit of their time?
我也注意到了。好吧，现在内德要继续他关于他想在报社做的事情的推销。他是这么说的。他说，引述如下：“如果你曾经想成为第一个知道你所居住的地方发生的事情的人，或者如果你想确保管理你们城市的那些人说的是真话，做他们说过他们会做的事，或者如果你只是支持弱者，想给那些夸夸其谈的人一点颜色看看，我们非常欢迎在座的各位到这家报社来做志愿者。”因为他说，我雇不起你们。嗯。他在房间对面发现了马尔。他说，马尔，这样可以吗？大家可以花一点时间吗？
Yeah, top boss Marv has come in. Yeah. And Marv says, okay. And you can kind of see in the room some people are feeling inspired. Yeah. And then he ends his speech. He wants to address the Me Too thing. The not Me Too email.
是的，大老板马尔进来了。是的。马尔说，可以。你能从房间里看出有些人受到了启发。是的。然后他结束了他的演讲。他想谈谈“MeToo”的事。那封“没有被MeToo”的邮件。
Correct. He says, by the way, me didn't. Me wouldn't. Me believe in respect in workplace. Me haven't. And mare's like shaking them off. She's like, you're good. You're good. Yeah, it's fine. Esmeralda is not happy. Yes. She is ticked off. She throws a fit. And then we have this last parting shot of her. It's downstairs in the main huge lobby of the big building by the elevator banks. And she's in her coat leaving for the day. And she says, in America, there is a saying about accepting things you can't. not change. Well, we do not have that saying in Italy. I loved that quote so much. Well, you know, one of the reasons she's pissed is because Ned kicks her out of her office. Oh, yeah. Was that necessary, Ned? You couldn't have just... This is such a big open space. You can't
没错。他说，顺便说一句，我没。我不会。我相信职场尊重。我没有。而迈尔则像是在摆脱尴尬。她说，你挺好的。你挺好的。是的，没关系。埃斯梅拉达很不高兴。是的。她气坏了。她大发雷霆。然后我们看到了她最后离场的镜头。那是在楼下大楼大厅电梯区旁巨大的主大堂里。她穿着外套准备下班离开。她说，在美国，有一句关于接受那些你无法改变的事情的名言。好吧，我们在意大利可没有这句名言。我太喜欢那句名言了。好吧，你知道，她生气的其中一个原因是因为内德把她赶出了她的办公室。哦，对。这有必要吗，内德？你就不能……这是一个这么大的开放空间。你就找不到另一个区域了吗？
find another area? Another nook to call your own? You're going to kick her out of the big office? She has so much stuff in there. It's going to take her a long time to move. Well, we're going to see in the next episode. She's trying to move her stuff into a smaller space, and it's not going well. It's not fitting. Well, Ned is sitting, he's on his laptop, and he is watching this black and white documentary from the only old in 1971. And this is when we have our cameo alert. We're talking to the newspaper man played by Tracy Letts again. He's giving a tour of the printing press. And we see Michael Komen, who is playing sort of a newspaper printer man. Yeah. And they're clearly having this great conversation. I was happy for Michael.
另一个属于你自己的角落？你要把她赶出大办公室？她里面有那么多东西。她得花好长时间才能搬完。好吧，我们会在下一集里看到。她正试图把东西搬进一个更小的空间里，而且进展不太顺利。根本放不下。好吧，内德正坐着，他在用笔记本电脑，看着这部1971年老旧的黑白纪录片。这就是我们的客串预警。我们又跟特雷西·莱茨饰演的报社男对话了。他正在带人参观印刷机。我们看到了迈尔斯·科曼，他扮演的是某种报纸印刷工。是的。他们显然在进行一次很棒的对话。我为迈尔斯感到高兴。
Me too. Made me so happy. I mean, listen, I would definitely want to write myself into a scene with Tracy Letts. Are you kidding me? Yeah. Mare is going to now knock on the door. She's heading home for the night. She sees what he's watching. And she's like, you know what? I have something to show you that's pretty cool. They head down to the basement way in the bottom of the building, and Ned's trying to guess where they're going, and then she opens the door and in front of them, and it's so huge, is an old printing press. Yeah, she says, this is the original printing press, the thing you're seeing in this documentary. Yeah. So Greg told me they filmed this scene at the Santa Anita Racetrack. They have a printing room. at the Santa Anita racetrack.
我也是。让我太开心了。我是说，听着，我绝对想把自己写进一个有特雷西·莱茨的场景里。你在开玩笑吗？是的。迈尔现在来敲门了。她准备回家过夜。她看到了他在看什么。她说，你知道吗？我有些很酷的东西要给你看。他们前往大楼最底层的地下室，内德试图猜他们要去哪里，然后她打开门，在他们面前的是一台巨大无比的旧印刷机。是的，她说，这就是原始的印刷机，就是你在纪录片里看到的那台。是的。所以格雷格告诉我，他们是在圣安 Anita 赛马场拍摄这个场景的。他们有一个印刷室。在圣安 Anita 赛马场。
And he said the bigger working machines that you see in the black and white documentary were actually filmed at a place called Southwest Offset Printing in Gardinia, California. But this whole thing was inspired by Greg and Michael touring the small newspaper offices. He said they went into the basement of one of the buildings and saw these newspaper presses that were left over from when you actually printed newspapers that way. Michael said that they learned that back in the olden days, when they built these buildings and these presses, that you actually had to embed the press into the foundation of the building and then build the building around it. He said this was because when they were operational, they caused so much friction that they would have, like, shook everything in the building. So that that's why they had to be, like, literally embedded in the ground.
他说你在黑白纪录片中看到的那些更大的工作机器实际上是在加利福尼亚州加迪纳一个叫西南胶印的地方拍摄的。但这一切的灵感都来自于格雷格和迈尔斯参观小型报社。他说他们走进其中一栋大楼的地下室，看到了这些报纸印刷机，它们是当你真正用那种方式印刷报纸时遗留下来的。迈尔斯说他们了解到，在过去的好日子里，当他们建造这些建筑和这些印刷机时，你实际上必须将印刷机嵌入建筑的地基中，然后围绕它建造建筑。他说这是因为当它们运转时，它们会产生巨大的摩擦力，以至于会把建筑里的所有东西都震动起来。所以这就是为什么它们必须，像字面意思一样嵌入地下。
They are so big. I wanted to do a deep dive, but it would have been a whole episode on the origins of the printing press. The Library of Congress website has really some great information, but they have old pictures and drawings and schematics of these printing presses. Some of them themselves were multiple stories. Oh, Greg says that the one they saw was like three stories deep. He said it was like he'd gone into like the bowels of a Navy ship and there's all these metal. ladders that were going to the different levels. Yes. He said they loved it so much they had to incorporate it into the show.
它们太大了。我想深入研究一下，但这将是一整集关于印刷机起源的内容。国会图书馆网站上确实有一些很棒的信息，但他们有这些印刷机的老照片、图纸和电路图。其中一些本身就是多层的。哦，格雷格说他们看到的那台有三层楼深。他说这就像他进入了一艘海军军舰的内部，有所有这些通往不同层级的金属梯子。是的。他说他们太喜欢了，以至于必须把它融入到剧中。
I was so glad they did. And I love when Ned says, what happens if I press this button, it's a big red button. And Maher's like, I wouldn't do that. And he presses it and nothing happens because this printing press is old and no longer works. And then we cut to the documentary footage and the character John Stack is talking about what that red button does. and I think we should hear it. So that button down at the end of the machine, that's a magic button.
我太高兴他们这么做了。我特别喜欢内德说，“如果我按下这个按钮会发生什么”，那是一个大红按钮。迈尔说，“我可不会那样做”。然后他按了下去，什么也没发生，因为这台印刷机太旧了，已经不能用了。然后镜头切回到纪录片素材，角色约翰·斯塔克正在谈论那个红按钮的作用，我觉得我们应该听听看。机器末端那个按钮，那是个神奇的按钮。
We push that button and the machine starts to rumble the life and all of those people, the 900 people in this building, all of the information they've gathered, the stories they've found, all of that gets fed into the machine along with the paper and this goodnight process happens. It is a kind of alchemy. And what comes out, this end, is the truth.
我们按下那个按钮，机器开始轰鸣启动，所有那些人，这栋大楼里的900人，他们收集的所有信息，他们找到的故事，所有这一切连同纸张一起被送进机器，这个晚安过程就发生了。这是一种炼金术。而出来的东西，这一头，就是真相。
It's a truth teller. That's what we do. And I don't mean to be blasphemous, but I worship at the altar of this machine. Yeah, and that's how this episode ends. It's really touching. It really is. We go to credits, and at the end there is a tag. Well, we love our tag.
它是一个真相传达者。这就是我们所做的。我不是想亵渎神明，但我崇拜这台机器的圣坛。是的，这一集就是这样结束的。真的很感人。确实如此。我们进入演职员表，最后有一个彩蛋。好吧，我们爱我们的彩蛋。
We love our tags. Oscar is standing at the copy machine. The camera crew finds him, and he's like not having it. He's like, you know what? I'm going to make this footage unusable. And he just begins to say the most off-colored things, and they're having to bleep him like crazy. They're not doing a good job of bleeping him. You understand everything he's saying, by the way.
我们爱我们的彩蛋。奥斯卡正站在复印机旁。摄像团队找到了他，而他却不买账。他说，你知道吗？我要让这段素材无法使用。然后他开始说一些最出格的话，他们不得不疯狂地消音。他们消音做得可真不咋地。顺便说一句，他说的话你全都听得懂。
They did not have the same standards and practices we had. No. And that is ultimately how the pilot ends. I have to say a big thank you to Greg and Michael and the casting crew of the paper and the folks at Peacock for letting us visit and for talking to us about this great new show in the universe of the office. Yes, we just loved it so much. I am in. I can't wait to see what happens. Well done. Yay. A applause to everyone. And also a big thank you to Bobby Ray Schaefer, Oscar Nunez, and Stephen Sox for sending us those awesome audio clips. Oh, and we want to give a shout out to Stephen and Lori's podcast, if we knew then, which is the number one Down syndrome advocacy podcast. Yes, it's great.
他们可没有我们以前的标准和规范。没有。这就是试播集最终结束的方式。我必须向格雷格、迈尔斯、《办公室》的演员和剧组以及孔雀网的朋友们表示诚挚的感谢，感谢他们让我们参观，并跟我们谈论《办公室》宇宙中的这部伟大新剧。是的，我们太喜欢了。我入坑了。我迫不及待想看看接下来会发生什么。干得好。耶。为所有人鼓掌。还要非常感谢鲍比·雷·谢弗、奥斯卡·努涅斯和斯蒂芬·索克斯给我们发来这些超棒的音频剪辑。哦，我们要向斯蒂芬和洛瑞的播客《如果我们当时知道》致敬，这是唐氏综合症倡导播客的第一名。是的，太棒了。
They have created a beautiful community for parents of children with Down syndrome. We'll share a link to it in our stories. Thanks so much for listening, and we hope you have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by D. Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe.
他们为唐氏综合症患儿的父母创造了一个美丽的社区。我们将在我们的故事中分享它的链接。非常感谢大家的收听，希望你们过得愉快。感谢收听“办公室辣妈”。“办公室辣妈”是Audyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Audyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室辣妈”由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。谢谢。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。